ponctualité ponctualité tout alsacienne
aujourd'hui donc merci Monsieur dorosuke
et Monsieur guibta d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de la commission d'enquête
chargée d'établir les raisons de la
perte de souveraineté d'un indépendance
énergétique de la France qui va
aujourd'hui procéder à deux Audi à une
audition
la seconde ayant été décalée pour des
raisons
d'ordre personnel je vous remercie
messieurs d'avoir accepté de venir
devant notre commission d'enquête pour
présenter notamment le rôle de la SN
dans le domaine de l'énergie
quelques petits rappels succins la SN a
été créée par la loi du 13 juin 2006 au
terme d'une longue gestation et
constitue une autorité indépendante que
ses compétences s'étendent bien au-delà
des seuls nucléaires en particulier
également dans le domaine médical qui
utilise largement des radios élément les
auditions qui ont été organisées dans le
cadre de nos travaux ont pour la plupart
rendu hommage à l'institution que vous
pilotez conjointement en tant que
président et en tant que que directeur
général la qualité des travaux de la SN
et son utilité ainsi que son
indépendance sont reconnus non seulement
par les acteurs de la filière nucléaire
mais aussi par le public et par les
instances étrangères et internationales
cependant des interrogations
apparaissent ici au la notamment quand à
la façon dont certaines alertes
peut-être
périphériques à la aux propres questions
de sûreté et aux questions plus
systémiques qui
intègre forcément des questions dessus
de sûreté ont pu ont pu exister les
garanties sont-elles dans certains cas
excessive par rapport à ce qui peut être
demandé dans d'autres pays c'est aussi
une question qu'on a pu se poser
qu'en est-il des délais d'instruction
l'intervention de la SN parfois est-elle
plus présente encore dans les procédures
que les procédures ne le prévoit voilà
je rappelle qu'un texte est actuellement
examiné par le Sénat qui vivent vise à
simplifier certaines procédures autour
de la construction de centrales
nucléaire par ailleurs et on le comprend
la sécurité et la sûreté nucléaire
relève non seulement de réglementation
nationale mais doivent également
respecter des prescriptions à la fois
internationales et européennes un
questionnaire préparé par le rapporteur
vous a été transmis afin de guider vos
propos notamment à vos propos liminaires
je vais de suite vous laisser la parole
mais avant cela il me revient de vous
demander de bien vouloir prêter serment
en implication de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires je vous
demande de bien vouloir prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité et
rien que la vérité je vous prie donc si
les deux intervenus de successivement
lever la main droite et dire je le jure
c'est bien noté mais écoutez je vous
laisse la parole
très bien
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés merci tout d'abord de nous
accueillir ici dans cet enceinte pour
cette audition concernant un sujet tout
à fait majeur celui effectivement de
l'indépendance et la souveraineté
énergétique de notre pays et en
particulier dans le domaine nucléaire
donc je suis accompagné comme vous
l'avez dit du d'Olivier gulpta qui est
directeur général de l'ASN et à tous les
deux tous les deux pardon nous nous
couvrons une certaine manière une partie
une partie de la période d'activité qui
est dans le champ de votre enquête mais
pas entièrement il y a parfois pour l'un
pour l'autre des moments où n'étions en
responsabilité ni l'un ni l'autre à la
scène
pour ma part quand vous l'avez dit je
suis le président de l'Autorité de
Sûreté Nucléaire j'ai été nommé en
novembre 2018
je n'ai pas été amené auparavant à
intervenir dans les prises de position
de l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire j'ai
occupé certes auparavant des fonctions
de délégués territoriale de l'Autorité
de sûreté entre 2003 et 2013 mais ces
fonctions je les ai exercées lorsque
j'étais directeur régional de
l'Industrie de la Recherche et de
l'Environnement c'était bon la fonction
principale dans les régions Centre et
Île-de-France je n'ai pas à cette
occasion en tant que délégué territorial
de la SN était amené à intervenir au
niveau décisionnel de la SN c'est donc
sur la période de novembre 2018 à
aujourd'hui que j'interviendrai de
manière spécifique
donc tout d'abord au cours de cette
période et regardez sujet que vous
évoquez vous abordez au sein de la
commission je peux indiquer que j'ai été
impliqué dans trois principales
décisions
qui je suppose seront réévoqués
aujourd'hui au cours de cette audition
il s'agit tout d'abord d'une décision de
joint 2019
concernant la réparation des soudures de
des traversées enceintes de l'EPR de
Flamanville qui a conduit un programme
de réparation d'ampleur et qui a conduit
également à ce que il y a un report
conséquent de la mise en service de le
père de Flamanville
la deuxième décision c'est celle de
prise en février 2021 elle concerne la
partie générique du réexamen de sûreté
du quatrième examen de sûreté des
réacteurs de 900 MW et cette décision
générique est suivie de décision
spécifique sur chacun des réacteurs ces
décisions sèches le nom au fur et à
mesure des 4e visites décédales de ces
réacteurs et elles vont se poursuivre 11
ont déjà été 11 auraient examens guide
décédales pardon déjà été réalisés sur
32 réacteurs et l'ensemble des réexamens
spécifiques s'échouera jusqu'à 2034
et enfin plus récemment en juillet 2022
une prise de position de la SN sur la
stratégie de contrôle et de réparation
des réacteurs d'EDF qui était affectés
de corrosion sous contrainte voilà 3
décisions qui me semblent avoir marqué
particulièrement cette période il y en a
eu beaucoup d'autres mais celle-là sont
certainement les plus en rapport avec
les sujets que vous avez ok au sein de
la Commission en introduction pour être
bref je j'évoquerai deux points tout
d'abord comme vous l'avez vous me l'avez
demandé je ferai un bref rappel des
missions de l'Autorité de Sûreté
Nucléaire et ensuite je ferai quelques
remarques sur la problématique qui est
étudiée au sein de cette commission mais
en me plaçant vu du point de vue de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire
donc tout d'abord l'émission de l'ASN
donc vous l'avez dit l'autorité la SN
est une autorité de sûreté indépendante
qui a été créée en 2006
l'émission de la SN concerne le contrôle
de la sûreté des installations
nucléaires civiles et le contrôle de la
radioprotection tant dans les domaines
médicaux industriels que pour le
transport des matières radioactives
la SN n'est pas compétente pour le
contrôle des installations nucléaires
militaires ce contrôle et du ressort de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire de
défense qui est un des services
rattachés au ministère des armées par
ailleurs et contrairement à ces
homologues à l'étranger la SN n'est pas
compétente pour le contrôle de la
sécurité des installations nucléaires
civiles c'est-à-dire la le contrôle de
la lutte contre les actes de
malveillance tout ce qui est concerne
l'intrusion ce qui concerne la
cybersécurité en France c'est le haut
fonctionnaire de défense du ministère de
l'écologie qui en est responsable
de par la loi la mission de l'ASM et
concerne exclusivement le contrôle de la
sûreté et de la radioprotection pour la
protection des personnes et de
l'environnement ainsi que la formation
du public la SN n'a aucune compétence en
matière de définition de la politique
énergétique de la France nous exerçons 5
missions principales la première
consiste à réglementer c'est-à-dire que
nous définissons les règles générales
qui sont applicables aux installations
nucléaires et aux activités nucléaires
en liaison avec les ministères
compétents ça peut être le Ministère
chargé la transition écologique
transition énergétique au ministère de
la Santé par exemple nous autorisons les
activités et les installations à
fonctionner en précisant les
prescriptions spécifiques qui viennent
s'ajouter aux prescriptions générales
pour chacune de ces activités ou de ces
installations nous contrôlons ensuite le
respect de ces dispositions général et
spécifiques dans chacune de ces
activités et de ses installations et
enfin nous informons le public sur
l'état de la sûreté et la
radioprotection nous informons le public
sur les décisions que nous sommes à
prendre et nous assistons participons à
la gestion des situations d'urgence
auprès du gouvernement
pour exercer ces missions la SN s'appuie
sur des ressources qui sont propres qui
sont répartis au boîtier à peu près au
siège de l'ASM qui est à Montrouge et
pour autre boîtier dans des directions
dans des divisions pardon territoriales
qui sont répartis dans 11 régions et
c'est nous sommes la seule autorité
administrative indépendante à disposer
d'un réseau territorial c'est mignon
liés à notre mission de contrôle et qui
est tout à fait spécifique
nous bénéficions principalement d'un
appui technique c'est celui de l'IRSN
et nous disposons également de groupes
d'experts qui sont placés directement
auprès de la SN
nous rendons compte au Parlement
notamment diverses commissions
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat et
nous présentons chaque année notre
rapport sur l'état de la sûreté et de la
radioprotection en France à l'OPEX
nous sommes très impliqués vous l'avez
dit au niveau international je crois que
même que nous sommes reconnus au niveau
international
dont en Europe que dans le monde alors
au regard de notre expérience
regarde l'importance du parc nucléaire
français qui permet d'un divan
d'alimenter cette expérience et puis du
niveau de sûreté et de radioprotection
qui est appliquée en France voilà je
n'en dirai pas plus pour ce qui concerne
la SN donc maintenant quelques remarques
du point de vue du point de vue de la SN
sur l'indépendance et la souveraineté au
cœur de votre réflexion alors tout
d'abord je n'ajouterai pas de définition
de la de la souveraineté par rapport à
celle qui ont des yeux a été fournies à
votre commission j'ai vu que vous en
aviez de nombreuses hasarderai pas en
ajouter une supplémentaire tout à fait
tout à fait je pense que vous avez
matière donc je vais simplement me
limiter à souligner deux points
principaux au regard de nos missions
le premier point concerne l'intégration
des enjeux de la sûreté et de la
radioprotection dans la politique
énergétique donc comme je l'ai préciser
la SN n'a pas à se prononcer sur la
politique énergétique du gouvernement
néanmoins la SN peut être amenée à
apprendre des positions à exprimer un
avis
publiquement sur les enjeux de sûreté et
de radioproduction qui doivent selon
elles être pris en compte par le
gouvernement dans la définition de la
politique énergétique française
cette un élément qui est important
puisqu'il peut effectivement sur
certains aspects contribuer au
renforcement de l'indépendance et de la
souveraineté de la France en matière
énergétique à cet égard depuis quelques
années la SN souligne en particulier
deux enjeux principaux le premier enjeu
qui est évoqué de manière récurrente
depuis le milieu des années 2000 de
manière informelle puis de manière
formelle par l'ASN dans son avis du 16
mai
13 rendu dans le cadre de du débat sur
la politique énergétique concerne le
besoin de conserver des marges dans le
système électrique pour pouvoir faire
face aux enjeux de sûreté en cas
d'événements génériques sur le parc
nucléaire
je dirais que c'est un avis donc vous
avez fait à plusieurs reprises à état et
qui est tout à fait important voire qui
s'est prouvé avéré dans les dans les
années qui ont suivi de tel événements
ne sont ce sont déjà produits
effectivement comme par exemple lors de
l'hiver
2016-2017 pendant lequel la SN a été
amenée à demander le contrôle sur 12
générateurs de vapeur et parc nucléaire
contrôle qui visait à vérifier qu'il n'y
avait pas de risque lié à des excès de
carbone qui pouvaient générer des
risques de rupture brutale pour les
parties de ces générateurs de vapeur ces
contrôles ont été faits pendant la
période hivernale sur une période courte
de trois mois vous pouvez avoir des
incidences en ce qui concerne la
disponibilité du parc pendant cette
période
cet événement certaines jusqu'à présent
le plus important en termes de risque de
défaut générique il a été largement
dépassé par le risque
apparu à des divers 2021-2022 suite à la
découverte de corrosion sous contrainte
sur certaines parties des circuits
d'injection de sécurité du parc qui
aurait pu conduire à un défaut générique
concernant tous les réacteurs en France
le second enjeu qui avait été également
évoqué en 2013 mais qui a été très
largement approfondie détaillé étendu
depuis 2019 concerne le besoin
d'anticipation des enjeux de sûreté et
de radioprotection
donc cet enjeu concerne particulièrement
la durée de fonctionnement des
installations nucléaires sont
aujourd'hui en service concerne bien sûr
les réacteurs du parc nucléaire d'EDF
mais également les installations du
cycle du combustible cet enjeu
d'anticipation concerne également le
risque de saturation des capacités
d'entreposage des matières ou des
déchets nucléaires situations que nous
avons fragiles que nous avons connu il y
a un an deux et qui est encore un sujet
de vigilance pour nous en matière de
d'anthroposage des combustibusés et plus
récemment les enjeux liés au
réchauffement climatique qui doivent
être anticipées sur de très longues
périodes donc ces deux sujets qui de
manière récurrente ont été évoquées par
l'Autorité de sûreté nucléaire qui
pouvait orienter le gouvernement dans la
définition de sa politique énergétique
concernée ce besoin de marge pour la
sûreté dans le dimensionnement du
système électrique et la nécessité les
enjeux de sûreté et de radioprotection
sur les installations en service
le second point que je voudrais évoquer
concerne la présence en France d'une
infrastructure de contrôle et
d'expertise qui est à la fois compétente
reconnue
à travers la scène et son appui
technique irln et qui dispose de
ressources nécessaires pour assurer sa
mission de contrôle et de contrôle de la
sûreté en toute autonomie c'est à la
fois important pour l'indépendance des
autorités mais c'est aussi nécessaire en
termes de souveraineté de la France
contrairement à certains de nos
homologues la SN est en mesure
de décider de
réaliser sa propre analyse en s'appuyant
sur des groupes d'experts qui existent
en France qui ont tout ce qu'ils ont de
haut niveau et de définir des règles qui
sont adaptées à la situation de notre
pays elle n'est pas n'a pas besoin pour
cela même si elle peut toujours
s'enrichir de l'expérience étrangère et
n'a pas besoin de faire appel
des expertises étrangères et à des
autorités étrangères pour pouvoir
prendre ses décisions
l'ASN et les règles qui définit
constitue
les règles que la SN établit constitue
une référence au niveau international
elle s'inspire bien souvent les
démarches et les processus de
convergence qu'ils ont mises en place
qui sont mis en oeuvre tant au niveau
européen qu'au niveau mondial je
pourrais citer quelques exemples la
démarche qui a été mise en Europe de
stress test suite à l'accident de
Fukushima est très fortement inspiré
d'une proposition qui avait formulé
l'ASN au niveau communautaire et cette
démarche a été déroulée partout en
Europe pas seulement d'ailleurs
communautaire et était à inspiré
également des démarches homologues
réalisées hors Europe
deuxième exemple les objectifs de sûreté
qui concerne les nouveaux réacteurs qui
ont été publiés en 2010 par
l'association wienera qui est
l'Association européenne des autorités
de contrôle dont actuellement Olivier
bucta et le président
ont été définis là encore en s'inspirant
des objectifs de sûreté qui avait été
définis en France pour le Pr donc il y a
eu une capacité de l'autorité de
françaises l'Autorité de sûreté
française à assemé d'une certaine
manière son expérience
encore un autre exemple la révision de
la directive euratum réalisée en 2014
qui a prévu que les réexamens
périodiques de sûreté devait viser à se
rapprocher du niveau de sûreté des
réacteurs nouveaux directeur neuf
regarde des références qui avaient été
publiées en 2010 a été là aussi
introduite pour pouvoir s'appliquer à
l'ensemble de l'Europe sous
sur la base de la référence et de
l'expérience connue en France c'est la
même chose de la déclaration de Vienne
de la UEA de 2015 qui incite au niveau
mondial les états attendent autant que
possible vers cette convergence entre
les réacteurs nouveaux et les réacteurs
en service dans le cadre des réexamens
des revues périodiques de sûreté là
encore c'est un processus de convergence
qui s'est opéré sur la base de
l'expérience française
donc cette capacité à fédérer à faire
travailler enfant ensemble les autorités
étrangères sur des sujets communs à
influencer les référentiels
internationaux et quelque chose qui me
semble extrêmement important à préserver
dans le cadre de vos réflexions sur
l'indépendance et la souveraineté un
dernier exemple qui a un exemple
d'actualité qui est illustre également
cette capacité à faire à fédérer à faire
travailler ensemble nous avons pris il y
a maintenant plus d'années d'une année
une initiative qui était unique au
moment où elle a été prise qui consiste
à travailler avec deux autres autorités
européennes notre homologue finlandais
notre homologue tchèque sur la un
travail
préalable sur les options de sûreté du
réacteur new Ward du SMR new-world et
nous avons ciblé des pays européens qui
étaient des pays dans lesquels EDF
estimait possible d'avoir
marché potentiel pour ce futur réacteur
donc là encore par anticipation en
travaillant avec nos homologues
étrangers nous sommes capables
d'influencer une démarche de convergence
au niveau au niveau des autorités de
sûreté
donc pour ceux qui me concerne je pense
que le maintien voir leur renforcement
des capacités et des compétences de la
SF et de l'IRSN constitue un véritable
enjeu de souveraineté voilà ce que je
voulais dire en propose
merci peut-être pour
sans sans répéter mais donner quelques
éléments sur à la fois sur mon parcours
et puis un éclairage de ma part donc
pour ma part j'ai travaillé à l'Autorité
de Sûreté Nucléaire d'abord de 1999 à
2011 j'ai
occupé plusieurs postes dans le domaine
du contrôle des réacteurs nucléaires en
particulier celui de directeur en charge
des réacteurs nucléaires et puis le
directeur général adjoint donc de la SN
j'en suis parti entre 2011 et 2016 donc
c'est une période finalement qu'aucun de
nous deux ne couvrons j'ai
occupé à cette période des fonctions de
directeur général adjoint de Météo
France donc des fonctions non plus de
contrôleur mais d'opérateurs
et donc je suis revenu en septembre 2016
à la SN en tant que directeur général et
par ailleurs je préside depuis fin 2019
l'association des responsables
d'autorité de sûreté d'Europe
alors peut-être simplement deux
réflexions en lien avec les travaux de
votre commission
l'une sur les exigences de sûreté et le
contrôle en général et l'autre sur
l'influence de la SN à l'international
qui rejoint tout à fait les derniers
propos de Bernard de rosuk
je dis je suis arrivé à la SN en 1999 et
j'ai connu depuis plusieurs cycles de
grâce et de disgrâce du nucléaire avec à
chaque fois le même type de de position
des partis prenantes qui les
accompagnent sur dans un cas le trop
dans l'autre le trop peu de sûreté
et une constante pour moi et pour la SN
en général a été finalement
indépendamment de cela tant créer le
contrôle sur quelques principes
fondamentaux des principes en général
internationalement reconnus
et sont dévier de ses principes à la
fois par conviction mais aussi pour
offrir aux industriels une stabilité qui
est nécessaire dans ce secteur
je cite quelques-uns de ces principes
d'abord le principe de responsabilité
première des exploitants c'est à dire
que le contrôle doit s'exercer sans des
responsabiliser l'exploitants c'est
prendre la place de l'exploitant c'est
toujours un équilibre
qu'il faut trouver
deuxième principe important celui de la
proportion du contrôle mais aussi des
décisions aux enjeux
c'est un principe sur lequel nous avons
beaucoup travaillé ces dernières années
et que nous continuons de renforcer
et enfin le principe d'un dialogue
technique approfondi avec les
industriels
j'insiste sur ce dernier point parce que
au fond plus que la réglementation on
parle souvent de d'exigence
réglementaire etc mais en réalité plus
que la réglementation c'est ce dialogue
technique approfondi qui permet
d'obtenir à la fin des fins le meilleur
niveau de sûreté qui est raisonnablement
possible
parce que c'est par la confrontation au
sens positif du terme avec les
industriels sur des arguments techniques
et de faisabilité industrielle que nous
définissons finalement
ce meilleur niveau de sûreté
raisonnablement atteignable
deuxième point j'ai toujours été
convaincu que la la discussion et le
travail en lien avec nos homologues
étrangers était absolument essentiels à
notre activité et ce dans les deux sens
à la fois naturellement pour s'inspirer
des pratiques qui
sont en vigueur à l'étranger en termes
de contrôle ou en termes de niveau
d'exigence mais aussi pour promouvoir
les pratiques françaises à
l'international
bernardozuk a cité plusieurs exemples et
effectivement il y en a un qui me tient
à cœur c'est celui des stress test parce
que j'ai été réellement à l'origine du
cahier des charges des stress test à
l'époque
et on voit comment ce ces stressait son
fait école non seulement en Europe mais
plus largement et ce sont eux qui ont
servi de base à toutes les améliorations
de sûretés peuvent se Fukushima donc il
y a réellement une communauté finalement
de vue qui s'est créé à cette occasion
là et de la même manière les objectifs
de sûreté
défini là aussi porté par l'association
wiendra en 2010 sur les nouveaux
réacteurs et donc à l'échelle européenne
ils sont très largement inspirés y
compris d'ailleurs dans leur formulation
même des objectifs de sûreté qui avait
été édictés par l'ASN pour les réacteurs
de type per donc on voit là en fait au
travers de ces types d'implication
alors en particulier à l'échelle
européenne mais l'échelle européenne
elle est essentielle pour finalement
ensuite porter plus loin au-delà de
l'Europe la voie de la France c'est un
point d'appui en quelque sorte on voit
donc au travers de ces deux exemples
qu'on vient c'est finalement cet outil
est puissant pour nous permettre
d'influencer
les autres pays et effectivement
à faire en sorte que le notre vision de
la sûreté face école plus largement
qu'en France le le dernier exemple dans
ce domaine c'est ce qui se fait
actuellement autour du suivi de la
situation en Ukraine avec tout un
travail de préparation des autorités
pour être capable de de réagir de façon
la plus conjointe commune possible en
cas d'incident ou d'accident et faire en
sorte finalement que la France soit en
capacité de disposer de des bonnes
informations
pour pour faire face à la situation
voilà que j'en dis pas plus à ce stade
et je contribuerai à répondre également
à vos questions en tant que besoin
merci beaucoup pour ces propos qui sont
déjà très complets donc j'aurais une
série de questions le rapporteur
également et puis après on va circuler
la parole au sein de la commission
d'enquête
[Musique]
d'abord j'aurai une première question
qui est vraiment d'ordre organisationnel
du système de contrôle de d'autorité
indépendante et qui est en réalité le
lien le dialogue que vous entrez
entretenez notamment avec l'IRSN
ce que finalement la SNC si je comprends
bien mais parfois il y a des il y a des
billets
est une autorité administrative
votre expertise n'est pas elle n'est pas
principalement internalisé elle est
externalisée notamment à l'IRSN
qu'est-ce qui justifie ce choix est-ce
qu'il est toujours optimum est-ce qu'il
y aurait besoin parfois d'internaliser
un certain nombre de compétences de de
base ou est-ce que ça fonctionne à
l'optimum comme ça
sans heure et
alors effectivement l'IRSN et l'expert
technique je dirais privilégié de l'ASM
il est possible que la SN dans un
certain nombre de circonstances plutôt
exceptionnel puisse faire appel à
d'autres experts techniques mais l'IRSN
a une reconstruction du système français
le l'expert technique privilégié de la
SN
cette situation n'est pas n'est pas la
même à l'étranger
la situation autorité experte peut
prendre différentes formes et à
l'étranger on trouve grosso modo trois
types de structures de relations entre
l'autorité et l'expert technique il y a
dans le monde des autorités de sûreté
qui ont
l'expertise intégrée et donc il n'y a
pas d'experts séparés c'est une seule
autorité qui comporte à la fois la
capacité d'expertise et le pouvoir de
décision c'est le cas par exemple aux
États-Unis avec la
NRC
c'est le cas en général d'ailleurs des
pays assez développés au niveau
nucléaire c'est le cas au Japon aussi
deuxième modèle les entités sont
séparées il y a un expert et il y a une
autorité mais l'expert est sous je
dirais la tutelle de l'autorité
c'est le cas par exemple en Belgique
c'est pas le cas en France et puis il y
a un troisième modèle ou l'expert et
l'autorité sont séparés mais il y a
plusieurs experts
le l'autorité et commanditaire elle
choisit son expert en fonction de sa
spécificité la disponibilité de ses
compétences et elle peut même faire
appel si elle le souhaite dans des cas
particuliers à des experts à l'étranger
notamment lorsqu'elle estime nécessaire
de faire une contre-expertise
c'est le cas en Grande-Bretagne
c'est le cas dans d'autres pays la Corée
par exemple
le modèle français
ne correspond à aucun de ces trois
modèles qui sont les modèles les les
plus répandus dans le monde nous nous
avons une situation il y a un seul
expert technique qui est Irène la
qualité technique des des avis de l'IRSN
et de très haut niveau reconnu tant en
France qu'à l'étranger donc la qualité
de l'expert ne pose pas de difficultés
parfois cette expert manque de moyens ou
de ressources pour pouvoir réaliser la
totalité des expertises que nous
demandons et c'est d'ailleurs la
situation aujourd'hui nous avons
beaucoup de sujets pour lesquels nous
demandons à l'IRSN de réaliser des
expertises et la le recrutement au sein
de l'URSS prend du temps la formation si
ce sont des experts de haut niveau et
donc il peut y avoir parfois une
difficulté et ça se traduit par des
priorités et nous définissons avec
l'IRSN quelles sont les dossiers
prioritaires ce qui conduit à ce que
certains dossiers soient plutôt mis en
deuxième voire en troisième position et
qui peut conduire à alléger alourdir
pardon un certain nombre de télé donc
voilà un peu la relation que nous avons
avec l'irsen
relation exclusive unique au monde ça
n'existe pas ailleurs et c'est une
relation à la fois qui repose sur une
expertise réelle mais qui peut poser
difficulté nous n'avons pas le choix
nous n'avons pas la maîtrise nous sommes
commandités nous n'avons pas la maîtrise
du budget d'expertise par exemple
c'est un le budget et géré par les
services de l'État ce qui pose pour nous
une difficulté en termes de rôle à
réaliser en tant que autorité
voilà ça c'est la relation avec avec
un second débat qui semble un peu à
animer le
Landerneau
on a entendu dans les auditions
successives contre le CEA et le
haut-commissaire à l'énergie atomique il
y avait questionnement sur est-ce que
c'est bien nécessaire d'avoir une
organisation bicéphale
quel est votre point de vue sur
l'organisation un peu bicéphale que vous
avez avec notamment le haut
fonctionnaire à la défense
les relations sont très claires je
dirais qu'il y a une volonté notamment
de la part du ministère de la désormais
compte tenu la spécificité des
installations de défense que le contrôle
des installations militaires soit
assurées par un service sous son
autorité donc il y a pas de déballage
dessus c'est d'ailleurs le cas très
souvent à l'étranger donc il y a pas de
différence contrairement à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur les
installations sur le contrôle de la
sécurité des installations civiles tous
mes homologues à l'étranger sont à la
fois compétents sur le contrôle de la
sûreté et de la sécurité des
installations civiles nous c'est
différent en revanche dans quasiment
tous les pays l'Autorité de sûreté
contre
compétente pardon pour les installations
civiles et pas la même que les
installations militaires en revanche
nous avons des installations des
installations notamment celles du CEA
qui d'une certaine manière à un moment
donné dans leur vie vont passer du
régime militaire au régime civil c'est
notamment le cas lorsqu'une installation
militaire
de défense arrête son activité et rentre
dans une phase de démantèlement ou
lorsqu'elle est soumise à des opérations
de reprise et de conditionnement de
déchets anciens donc là il faut qu'il y
ait une transition entre la SND et la SN
c'est ce que nous essayons de faire avec
la SND nous avons des contacts réguliers
et sur ces dossiers qui sont en
transition nous essayons d'anticiper la
phase de transition pour que il n'y ait
pas une marche à franchir quand on passe
d'un régime à l'autre voilà parfois ça
se passe bien bon c'est un peu plus
compliqué mais nous avons cette relation
avec avec la SND
alors peut-être je confondu est-ce que
c'était là SND ou la chef DS c'était
plutôt le haut fonctionnaire à la
défense je croyais que vous parliez des
installations militaires donc en ce qui
concerne le haut fonctionnaire des
défenses chargés de la sécurité des
installations civiles là effectivement
il y a aussi des interfaces à gérer
parce que là ça s'applique à la même
installation au même moment alors que
dans le cas que j'ai indiqué
précédemment c'est un continuum donc là
il est clair que cette situation elle
paraît paradoxale je l'ai indiqué que à
l'étranger ce n'est pas le cas et il y a
les paradoxal parce que il y a des
sujets communs qui doivent être traités
ensemble et qui parfois doit faire
l'objet d'un arbitrage entre la sécurité
et la sûreté je prends un exemple assez
simple en ce qui nous concerne au titre
de la sûreté on peut être amené à
privilégier une évacuation rapide par
rapport à la zone qui est qui est
accidentée ou qui est soumise à risque
pour ce qui concerne au fonctionnaires
de défense pour des raisons de lutte
contre l'intrusion ça peut être
l'inverse ça peut être de dire il faut
retarder des conditions d'accès à
l'intérieur donc il faut trouver un
arbitrage lorsque nous nous étudions au
titre de la démonstration de sûreté
l'incidence d'un impact extérieur
notamment d'un avion sur le
dôme d'un bâtiment réacteur pour nous
l'avions il tombe de manière fortuite
c'est-à-dire il sait pas volontairement
que que l'avion vise le dôme du réacteur
et donc l'impact en termes d'énergie
n'est pas le même que celui que doit
prendre en compte l'autorité de HFDS qui
lui a étudié le même sujet la résistance
du dôme au titre de l'acte de
malveillance et là l'acte de
malveillance c'est on cible bien avec le
maximum d'impact le maximum d'énergie
pour pouvoir le faire les plus gros
dégâts et pourtant dans les deux cas la
manière de résister à cet impact c'est
la même c'est le c'est le même c'est le
dimensionnement de l'enceinte c'est ce
qui est raccordé à l'enceinte parce que
il va y avoir des vibrations internes
liées au choc et donc il faut regarder
ce sujet de manière globale et pourtant
aujourd'hui on le regarde de manière
successive le H le fonctionnaire de
défense le regarde et la SL le regarde
donc là il y a et ce n'est pas une
position nouvelle de la SN les positions
que nous réaffirmons de manière
régulière notamment lors des auditions
parlementaires estimons que en France il
devrait y avoir une seule autorité
compétente à la fois pour la sûr que la
sûreté et la sécurité des installations
civiques
très bien merci beaucoup vous avez
pas mal abordé le regard que les
institutions internationales peuvent
porter sur sur l'ASN et puis le la
capacité d'entraînement qu'elle a sur
les institutions semblables
internationales j'aurais deux questions
de ce point de vue là la première c'est
au-delà du de l'excellence de la SN
quelle est le rôle de la spécificité de
l'organisation de l'exploitation
nucléaire française
dans cette force que peut avoir la SN à
l'international je je précise le fait
qu'on est qu'un seul exploitant
nucléaire en France est-ce que ça joue
un rôle dans la crédibilité est-ce que
ça joue aussi un rôle dans le travail au
quotidien que vous avez
à la SN
alors il y a deux particularités qui ont
besoin d'aller cité une le fait qu'on
est qu'un seul exploitant pour 56
aujourd'hui réacteurs fait que bien
évidemment on accumule de l'expérience
plus rapidement que que d'autres ce qui
est peut être découvert sur un réacteur
peut-être immédiatement exploité sur la
totalité du parc alors que dans un dans
les pays où chaque exploitant est
différent c'est plus compliqué il y a
des partages de retours d'expérience au
niveau de ces pays et c'est le plus
compliqué en termes de décision et
d'action homogène à réaliser sur
l'ensemble d'un même parc de réacteurs
donc ça c'est une spécificité française
c'est une force en termes de retour
d'expérience mais c'est une faiblesse en
termes de risque de défaut génériques je
veux dire bien pas donc ça c'est une
spécificité française la deuxième fécité
française c'est le fait que nous ayons
une
une chaîne de d'industriels du nucléaire
qui couvre la totalité du système
nucléaire dans qui concerne la
fabrication des combustibles le
retraitement des combustibles la bien
sûr l'exploitation
l'exploitation de réacteur exploitation
de recherche donc on a vraiment une
panoplie complète
et capacités de recherche sur ces
différentes composantes qui nous
différencient de certains de nos
homologues à l'étranger et nous avons y
compris dans le domaine des de la
gestion des déchets
une avancée je crois surtout par rapport
au sujet le plus sensible qui concerne
le stockage des déchets à haute activité
bilan avec le projet cigaux ou là encore
nous avons une capacité à
gérer des projets à engager des
discussions parlementaires et techniques
pour pouvoir aboutir à une solution qui
est difficile à mettre en oeuvre mais
qui a au moins avancé nous sommes parmi
les trois pays au monde les plus avancés
sur sur ce projet et peut-être que
Olivier
la masse de retour d'expérience est
cumulée fait que nos homologues sont
souvent très intéressés par les sujets
qu'on a à leur présenter et je pense
prendre l'exemple de la corrosion sous
contrainte voilà on a eu beaucoup
d'écoute de la part de nos homologues
qui effectivement eux-mêmes ont
cherchent aussi à voir si la situation
et la même ou pas dans leur propre pays
bon il semble qu'il y a des spécificités
françaises mais à chaque fois qu'il y a
un événement majeur
on est amené à en parler à nos
homologues j’ajoute que EDF à une
approche de ce point de vue très
transparente
de partage effectivement de du retour
d'expérience non seulement en France
mais plus largement et tout ça me paraît
effectivement extrêmement positif en
termes de sûreté y compris à
l'international
dans vos propos liminaires vous avez
tous deux souligné l'influence qui avait
la SN et le système français à produire
de la norme internationale d'un point de
vue de la sûreté ou à influencer en tout
cas de la norme internationale
on est du coup un peu surpris de du
décalage qui peut y avoir entre
la crédibilité française sur ce sujet là
et le peu d'écoute de la France sur les
visions plus systémiques du système
électrique je pense notamment au niveau
européen on a peut-être plus de mal à
faire comprendre notre système
électrique
basé en grande partie sur le nucléaire
ou en tout cas à obtenir des arbitrages
de ce point de vue là est-ce que vous
voyez des des différences d'organisation
majeures entre finalement le la filière
de la sûreté de du contrôle de la sûreté
puis la filière plus peut-être plus
politique de de la production
difficile à dire je dirais que vous-même
dans la formulation de la question vous
donnez un élément de réponse c'est que
les autorités de sûreté ne sont pas des
autorités politiques et elles ont
s'appuie sur des éléments qui sont
rationnels qui sont techniques qui sont
démontrées et les échanges techniques
sont entre experts sont parfois plus
faciles même si on n'est pas toujours
d'accord que lorsqu'il y a des enjeux de
politique des enjeux politiques
industriels en jeu économiques donc
qu'on a peut-être la partie la plus
facile même si nous sommes pas toujours
d'accord
comparativement à au débat que vous
évoquez en termes politiques oui
simplement pour peut-être pour compléter
il y a et je pense que c'est un facteur
qui a joué en faveur là dans le dans le
domaine nucléaire il y a énormément
finalement d'instances internationales
qui se sont créés enfin de cercle de
discussions on a évoqué WENRA mais il y
en a il y en a d'autres il y a aussi des
discussions donc à l'échelle
internationale dans le cadre de l'agence
internationale pour l'énergie de pour
l'énergie atomique à l'agence pour
l'énergie nucléaire il y a beaucoup de
cadres finalement dans lequel les
autorités
se trouvent en situation de discuter et
souvent sans j'allais dire de façon très
libre en fait sans sans comme l'évoquer
Bernard bourzuk d'un point de vue
purement technique et sans mandat
explicite de de leur pays ce qui fait
que on arrive peut-être plus facilement
à trouver des positions communes des
consensus c'est ce qui a été fait à
l'échelle européenne sur ces fameux
niveau de référence qui ont inspiré
ensuite la réglementation des différents
pays européens mais je pense que c'est
certainement un facteur qui a qui a joué
positivement
au cours nos auditions on a on a
auditionné tous les industriels français
enfin les grands industriels français de
la filière à Mont aval
j'ai le sentiment que tant chez EDF que
chez framatum que chez Orano il y a une
forme de prise de conscience
de la réalité de l'outil industriel
à l'occasion notamment du chantier de
Flamanville et de la nécessité de de le
remonter en technicité en
moyen etc
donc de gros investissements soit au
Creusot
Tricastin ou dans les filières chez EDF
quel regard portez-vous sur l'évolution
de l'ensemble de la filière à mon
notamment
nucléaire française
alors il est il est absolument
indéniable et je crois que c'est
vraiment reconnu
en plate que
l'industrie française du nucléaire a
souffert pendant une vingtaine d'années
de l'absence de grands projets et les
quelques grands projets qui qui ont été
lancés à partir des années 2000 ce sont
des projets qui en général ont eu des
difficultés dans leur déroulement qu'il
s'agisse de le père de Flamanville qui
s'agisse du réacteur RGH du CEA ou même
de l'installation ITER donc ce sont des
projets compliqués et la raison
principale de la difficulté de conduire
ces projets indépendamment de l'effet
masse l'effet série qui n'était pas
présent c'était des cas uniques à chaque
fois des installations uniques ou il ne
pouvait pas y avoir de processus
d'apprentissage qui ensuite le coût
d'après permettait de mieux faire
puisque il y avait qu'un seul kensan
installation a à construire et c'était
des installations toujours tête de série
la conception était nouvelle donc ça a
été relativement compliqué ça n'a pas
permis d'avoir ce processus
d'accumulation
surveillance et puis il y a eu une perte
de compétences cette perte de
compétences elle est essentiellement
liée à la désindustrialisation de notre
pays à partir des années 90 et le rythme
de possible de construction de réacteurs
je vois bien aujourd'hui de la part en
déclaration des de la filière elle-même
ne pourrait pas être le même que celui
que nous avons connu dans les années 80
donc une perte de compétences un
renouvellement des générations des
personnes d'expérience qui ont quitté
les entreprises qui ont été de manière
anticipées je pense notamment à EDF
remplacé mais par des gens qui n'avaient
pas d'expérience donc on a peut-être le
même nombre globalement mais avec un
cumul d'année d'expérience qui s'est
beaucoup abaissé donc ça c'est ce sont
les raisons de fond me semble-t-il qui
explique d'abord ces difficultés ensuite
il y a eu à l'évidence des faux dans la
gestion des défaillances dans la gestion
des projets le rapport de Jean-Martin
Folz le montre très nettement à travers
de l'exemple de de Flamanville avec un
nombre considérable de
manquement de
mauvaises de manque de rigueur
l'absence de d'une véritable gestion de
projet qui est venu
disons compliqués encore la situation
qui n'était pas sur des bases saines en
matière de compétence et d'expérience je
pense que la filière en a pris
conscience notamment du fait de des
événements du rapport de Jean-Martin
Foltz de la création du gifen de la
mobilisation de l'ensemble de la filière
industrielle le plan Excel qui a été
d'abord mis en place par EDF qui a été
d'ailleurs répliqué en grande partie par
les autres exploitants donc il y a une
filière qui aujourd'hui mobilisée et
c'est tant mieux parce que il y a
beaucoup de choses alors il y a d'abord
une mobilisation de la filière même si
ce n'est pas souvent dit qui était
indispensable dans les opérations de
grands carénages
il y avait finalement avant le lancement
du grand carénage qui est donc associé à
la quatrième visite décennale il y avait
très très peu de moyens de mobiliser les
compétences de la filière industrielle
et de les renforcer alors que c'est très
important bien évidemment ce n'est pas
de la même nature ni de la même ampleur
que l'ensemble des compétences qui sont
nécessaires pour la construction d'un
réacteur neuf c'est moins mais c'est
déjà une première marche et avec un
effet qui n'est pas négligeable
EDF estime que entre
2000 2020 et 2026 les travaux de grand
carénage conduisent pour la partie
mécanique la filière mécanique qui
comporte les échangeurs les pompes les
soudages le soudage la tuyauterie qu'il
y a un facteur 6 en termes d'appel aux
compétences donc on voit bien que un
facteur 6 entre 2000 et 2006 entre 2020
pardon et 2026 avec ensuite une
continuité jusqu'à 2030 ça conduit à à
des investissements à la fois en termes
de moyens techniques et en termes de
ressources à qualifier pour les
industriels de la filière qui sera fort
utile lorsque les mêmes industriels de
la mécanique seront sollicités pour la
construction de donc il y a eu un
premier effet de renforcement lié au
grand carénage mais la vraie marche
d'escalier ce sera bien évidemment la
mise en place si elle est décédée de du
programme du de construction de nouveaux
réacteurs avec d'autres corps de métiers
qui vont être impliqués qui n'ont pas
été dans le grand carénage je pense
notamment au génie civil ça va démarrer
par ça et ça va être énorme en termes de
gestion de chantier et là pour moi il y
a trois il y a trois sujets qui sont des
sujets de grande vigilance dont la
filière a conscience mais à mon avis pas
encore atteint en termes de capacité
d'abord un sujet de ressource et les
ressources c'est l'attractivité il y a
un vrai sujet d'attractivité de la
filière la filière indique
que dans les cinq ans qui viennent il
lui faudra recruter la moitié du
personnel dont elle aura besoin en 2030
plus de 150 000 personnes c'est
considérable il va lui falloir recruter
3000 ingénieurs chaque année pendant
plusieurs années de suite c'est aussi
considérable compte tenu du flux de
sortie des formations d'ingénieur donc
il va falloir attirer attirer dans la
filière attirer à un moment donné où les
viviers sont en faiblesses quand on voit
la perte de
d'attrait pour les filières
scientifiques les formations
professionnelles les formations
techniques il va falloir vraiment
changer de braquer et de dimensions
c'est l'effet d'une génération il faut
une géranération complète de qui va être
qui devrait être formé pour accompagner
un programme s'il est décidé qui durera
le temps au moins le temps d'une
génération donc il y a un effort
d'attractivité de maintien des
ressources d'anticipation sur les
questions de formation
former un soudeur c'est 2 à 3 ans former
un tuyauteur c'est 2 à 3 ans pendant
qu'il qui paye pendant qu'on le forme
donc il y a vraiment un sujet global en
termes de ressources et de formation
c'est le défi majeur le deuxième sujet
c'est celui bien sûr du défi financier
contenu des projets je monte en vrai pas
là dessus et le troisième défi c'est
celui de la gestion de projet avec les
défaillances que j'indiquais mais aussi
une gestion de projet qui embarque la
totalité de la filière donc il faut
effectivement donner de la visibilité à
la filière industrielle pour qu'elle
puisse investir il faut associer
davantage la filière à la fois dans la
connaissance des exigences à respecter
et dans le je dirais la manière la
rigueur et la manière de de le faire
pour nous ASN nous estimons que c'est un
sujet sur lequel nous devons prendre
parti on doit prendre parti pourquoi bah
parce que en fait la qualité de la
conception de la fabrication et du
contrôle c'est la première défense la
première ligne de défense en matière de
sûreté on ne peut pas dire c'est un
sujet industriel et nous on regardera le
résultat à la fin non on veut absolument
à travers notre mission de contrôle sur
la totalité de la filière regardez ces
sujets en termes de capacités techniques
à faire un programme une ambition hors
norme
j'arrive doucement à la fin de mes
questions mais une question qui
justement rebondit un petit peu sur ce
que vous venez de dire un des éléments
qui est mis en évidence dans les
défaillances de du projet EPR inflammant
ville
c'est le l'évolution progressive
du projet alors que les travaux avaient
commencé
ça m'emmène à une double question quelle
est la part d'évolution
normative prescriptive en matière de
sûreté qui a affecté le projet
Flamanville en cours de chantier
est-ce que vous avez pu
identifier des effets que ces évolutions
peut avoir sur sur le déroulement du
chantier et second élément c'est sur le
parti pris français en matière de sûreté
notamment dans le cadre des visites
décennales qui est la stratégie de
finalement le meilleur niveau de sûreté
disponible là où par exemple les
Américains
regardent la situation de sûreté par
rapport à l'autorisation initiale
comment est-ce que vous qualifieriez ce
parti pris français parce que il y a pas
il y a pas de il y a pas de jugement de
valeur de ma part là dessus et comment
surtout est-ce qu'un tel parti pris se
construit et arbitre
alors je pense que d'abord je
m'attendais à cette question et je pense
que ce sont deux sujets sur lesquels il
faut vraiment regarder les choses en
profondeur pour bien comprendre à la
fois le mécanisme de comme vous dites de
définition
des exigences ou des règles à respecter
en France et puis la manière dont tout
ça est ensuite appliquée et quel impact
ça peut avoir sur les projets alors je
prends dans l'ordre d'abord le sujet de
l'EPH c'est des gens entendu très
souvent depuis ma prise de fonction que
des évolutions réglementaires
considérées comme étant en cours de
projet pouvait être estimé comme étant
responsable de difficultés à réaliser à
terminer le projet c'est notamment la
question de l'arrêté ESPN c'est à dire
des équipements sous pression nucléaires
alors moi je voudrais être clair sur ce
sujet et je j'ai entendu certains des
personnes que vous avez auditionnées le
dire également d'abord l'arrêter de 2005
sur les équipements sous pression donc
prix après le démarrage du projet c'est
un arrêté qui n'est pas venu d'une
initiative purement de la SN de changer
la réglementation mais qui était le
résultat en fait d'une transposition
d'un besoin de transposition d'une
directive européenne sur les équipements
sous pression qu'il fallait mettre en
application en France elle était déjà en
application pour les équipements sous
pression traditionnelles classiques hors
nucléaire et là elle a été mis en oeuvre
pour les appareils à pressions
nucléaires bien évidemment ça a été
discuté avec les exploitants
s'est arrêté de 2005 prévoyait une
période de mise en oeuvre de 10 ans et
qui à l'époque était jugé comme étant
suffisante pour achever les projets qui
avaient été conçus et démarré suivant
l'ancienne réglementation qui datait de
1974 donc 10 ans pour aller jusqu'en
2015 on était en 2005
les industriels français ont estimé que
finalement il n'y avait pas lieu
d'attendre c'est leur décision nous on
va l'appliquer d'entrée de jeu
l'arrêté de 2005 au royaume c'est c'est
pas une prescription de la SN qui change
les règles du jeu en parcours c'est un
une évolution de la réglementation liée
par une évolution réglementaire au
niveau communautaire pour lesquels les
industriels français disent ben nous on
va l'appliquer c'est cette
réglementation elle est basée sur le
principe dite de la nouvelle approche
qui
qui est celle de l'harmonisation
européenne c'est à dire les exigences
sont des exigences essentielles elles
sont définies de manière très générale
comme étant des objectifs à atteindre et
les moyens sont définis par les codes ou
par les industriels donc il y avait une
exigence qui apparaissait simple qui
était de dire finalement il va falloir
faire de la qualification technique des
procédés que vous utilisez possédez ça
peut être le forgeal le soudage le
traitement thermique c'est un procédé
industriel quand vous utilisez un
procédé industriel vous devez le
qualifier pour démontrer auparavant que
il arrive il permet d'atteindre les
objectifs les industriels français ont
pensé qu'il pouvait sur la base de leur
expérience antérieure effectivement le
justifier
et puis donc le temps a passé et d'une
certaine manière
il y a eu des difficultés pour ceux qui
concerne la justification de la
qualification technique et le premier
sujet qui est apparu c'est celui de la
cuve de l'EPR donc beaucoup de temps
avant de déboucher sur une qualification
technique et les résultats de cette
qualification technique ont mis en
évidence un risque de ségrégation
carbone de concentration carbone
excessif dans dans la cuve à la fin dans
le fond de la cuve et dans le couvercle
bon c'était un sujet industriel d'une
certaine manière ce n'est pas la
réglementation qui est à l'origine de la
création de la ségrégation carbone mais
en revanche c'est l'application de la
réglementation qui a permis à travers
l'exigence de qualifications techniques
de découvrir cette ségrégation carbone
pourquoi il y avait-il une ségrégation
carbone alors qu'elle n'avait pas eu
précédemment mais parce que le procédé
industriel pour la cuve de l'EPR n'était
pas le même que la que la construction
des de tous les réacteurs précédents le
lingot de départ n'était pas le même la
cuve la taille de la cuve n'était pas la
même et donc il y avait eu à l'évidence
il y aurait eu un besoin de
qualifications techniques d'un nouveau
procédé et ça n'a pas été suffisamment
fait et donc conclusion lorsque
apostériori la qualification technique a
été faite sur des pièces sacrificielles
les mêmes que celles qui avaient permis
de faire la cuve là on a découvert la
ségrégation carbone donc voyez-vous
voilà c'est ça l'histoire c'est
d'ailleurs dans le rapport de
Jean-Martin Foltz ça s'est passé comme
ça et finalement ce n'est pas la
réglementation qui est en à l'origine
des retards moi je ne connais pas de
disposition réglementaire qui conduisent
à l'exégrégation carbone comme
d'ailleurs je ne connais pas de
disposition réglementaire qui conduisent
à ne pas faire les traitements
thermiques comme il faut ou à faire des
soudures comme sur le père les
traversées enceinte qui ne respectent
pas les exigences qui avaient été
respectées très largement dans le cadre
des réacteurs précéd très très largement
voilà donc mon point là il est très
clair c'est que il faut faire attention
lorsque l'on part sur cette voie de bien
regarder ce qui s'est passé réellement
ce n'est pas la mise en application de
l'arrêté de 2005 sur les appareils à
pression nucléaire qui est à l'origine
de découverte mais c'est plutôt un
manque de rigueur industriel un
défaillance en matière de qualification
de procédé pour ce qui concerne les
examens on a parlé un peu tout à l'heure
la il y a un consensus international
d'abord au niveau européen puis au
niveau international avec la IEA sur le
fait que le examen périodique doit viser
en tout cas recommandations c'est plus
une recommandation que une imposition
recommande de viser à l'occasion de la
réévaluation de sûreté qui réalisait au
examens de viser le niveau de sûreté des
réacteurs les plus récents ça c'est
c'est à la fois
décision qui figure dans la directive
ratop et qui figure dans la dans la
déclaration de Vienne de la IEA c'est ce
que nous appliquons
nous l'appliquons et logiquement les
autres autorités devraient s'en inspirer
alors elle son inspire plus ou moins ça
dépend bien évidemment aussi du contexte
local mais je pense qu'on ne peut pas
dire que nous sommes les seuls à avoir
cette vision qui consiste à au moment
des examens de sûreté à rapprocher le
niveau de sûreté autant que c'est
possible il s'agit pas de le faire à
tout prix mais autant que c'est possible
le niveau de sûreté atteint à l'issue du
réexamen des nouveaux des réacteurs en
service avec les nouveaux réacteurs
alors ça c'est le résultat aussi d'une
décision qui a été prise très tôt pour
ce qui concerne le quatrième examen de
sûreté le quatrième règlement de sûreté
des réacteurs
représentés véritablement une échéance
je dirais emblématique les réacteurs
d'EDF avaient été conçu c'est le cas
aussi aux États-Unis pour une durée
d'exploitation de 40 ans
la durée d'exploitation qui a été prise
en compte au moment de la conception
quand on approche de cet échéance bien
évidemment et qu'on veut aller plus loin
c'est d'ailleurs ce qui a été indiqué
par EDF je crois alors d'un conseil
d'administration en 2008 en disant bah
voilà nous voulons aller plus loin nous
voulons aller au-delà de 40 ans bien
évidemment il s'agit Jésus et savoir
mais dans quelles conditions on peut
aller plus loin et il y a eu un débat
qui est instauré un dialogue instaurer
entre EDF et l'ASM à l'époque et le
président de la SN de l'époque a écrit à
EDF après leur discussion un courrier
que je vois qu'il y a de juin 2010 dans
lequel il dit ben voilà au vu de nos
discussions compte tenu du fait qu'il y
a nepr qui est en construction qui nous
paraît pas judicieux d'avoir
sur le parc nucléaire français deux
niveaux de sûreté niveau de sûreté des
réacteurs anciens et niveaux de sûreté
nouveau de l'EPR ben dans le cas des
examens on est en 2010 leur examen
commence pour 2018 c'est 2018 la
première échéance de la vd4 donc il y a
8 ans d'avance il dit ben voilà on
discuter on est d'accord je crois
d'ailleurs que le président de l'époque
vous la confirmez il a dit ben voilà on
va se mettre d'accord pour ça
personnellement quand je regarde les
choses d'aujourd'hui quand je vois le
débat qui s'instaure sur la prolongation
de fonctionnement du réacteur actuel
jusqu'à 60 ans au-delà de 60 ans je
pense que c'était une décision assez
sage à l'occasion du passage de 40 ans
de dire que les réacteurs on va les
mettre le à un niveau de sûreté le plus
proche possible du réacteur européen et
si c'est le cas si finalement il est
possible de poursuivre l'exploitation
des réacteurs actuels jusqu'à 60 ans
voire au-delà de 60 ans ça veut dire
qu'il y aura au moins 20 ans peut-être
plus d'années où on aura un parc
homogène ce qui n'aurait pas été le cas
si nous avions pris l'approche telle
qu'elle est présentée par les Américains
donc je pense que voilà cette décision
elle est le résultat aussi d'une
acceptation est-ce qu'il y a eu pas mal
de concertation à l'époque d'une
acceptation par le public d'un passage
au-delà de il y a aussi cette
acceptation du nucléaire n'oublions pas
que en 2011 il y a accident de Fukushima
bien avant leur examen de 2018 pour
pouvoir accepter il n'y a pas eu
d'ailleurs de défiler contre pour
accepter l'idée d'aller au-delà de 40
ans il fallait d'une certaine manière se
fixer un objectif ambitieux
collectivement c'est ce qui a été fait
en visant le niveau de sûreté le plus
proche possible dans des conditions
économiques acceptables avec une cadence
qui soit industriellement soutenable et
on pourra y revenir de la mise en place
du du règlement sûreté voilà voilà le
contexte dans lequel on est alors
maintenant on est dans un autre contexte
je pense qu'on y reviendra plus tard
c'est maintenant mais au-delà quand dans
quelle perspective et comment peut-on
tirer profit éventuellement de
l'expérience américaine dans le futur
très bien monsieur le rapporteur merci
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Directeur Général
pour ces premiers éléments une série de
questions d'abord sur le parc en
lui-même et puis une série de questions
sur les normes qui régissent la SN et
votre éclairage d'abord une question
très naïve et vous vous m'en pardonnerez
vous avez dit que les missions de la SN
et je raccourcis mon excuserez porte
exclusivement sur l'appréciation de la
sûreté des installations nucléaires et
quand vous dites ça j'ai du mal à
comprendre le contenu des alertes que
vous formulez depuis 2013 sur la
capacité de la France à disposer de
marge pilotables bien sûr c'est du fait
d'un potentiel défaut de sûreté ou du
fait d'un défaut générique qui pour des
raisons de sûreté conduirait à la
fermeture partielle mais il me semble
bien qu'il s'agit là d'un avis sur la
politique énergétique du pays donc j'ai
un petit peu de mal à comprendre comment
ces alertes là s'articulent avec l'idée
que la SN n'aimait pas de jugement
finalement sur sur la politique
énergétique
alors ce qui est ce qui est tout à fait
clair c'est que dans l'intention
l'intention qui était celle de l'ASN au
moment de la vie de 2013 sur la future
poétique énergétique et le besoin de
marge pour faire face à des événements
génériques
l'élément qui était en tête de la SN à
l'époque c'est celui d'avoir
effectivement une espèce de mise en
tension du système de décision publique
entre une mise en concurrence d'une
certaine manière d'une décision de
sûreté qui aurait pu être celle
argumentée souhaité par l'ASN et une
décision publique qui aurait été celle
de préserver un autre intérêt général
qui était celui d'avoir une alimentation
électrique pour l'ensemble du pays donc
cette mise en concurrence d'ailleurs
c'est ce que nous avons vécu d'une
certaine manière un peu cet hiver cette
mise en concurrence d'un intérêt général
qui est celui de fournir un bien
précieux comme l'énergie et notamment
l'é l'ensemble de la nation par rapport
à un risque pour la totalité de la
nation d'un risque nucléaire c'est cette
situation là que nous redoutions et que
nous ne voulions pas voir apparaître
pour pouvoir y faire face ce que nous
pensions est-ce que nous pensons
toujours c'est qu'il faut disposer de
marches suffisante dans le système
électrique pour ne pas être dans cette
situation de mise en concurrence et là
je pense que nous sommes dans notre rôle
de dire parce que c'est nous qui devons
assumer la loi nous le confit une confie
cette responsabilité de dire à partir du
moment où un risque avéré et pour la
sûreté existe de le signaler c'est la
première niveau et puis si ce risque est
imminent c'est de prendre nous-mêmes la
décision de mettre à l'arrêt donc pour
éviter cette situation nous pensons que
il est peut-être préférable parce que
c'est possible de disposer de marge dans
le système électrique pour éviter cette
situation
pardon vous avez employé le terme de
risque avéré m'échappe un petit peu
qu'est-ce qu'un risque avéré c'est un
risque qui a déjà eu lieu ou je suis pas
sûr de comprendre ce que veut dire un
risque avéré
c'est un risque pour lequel une
probabilité forte existe je crois que
c'est d'ailleurs le texte du de la loi
risque pas me tromper je crois que c'est
le texte de la loi c'est pour ça que je
vais utiliser et quand je disais tout à
l'heure que notre mission notre seule
mission c'est la sûreté le contrôle de
la sûreté pas la sûreté le contrôle de
la sûreté la sûreté c'est l'exploitant
la contrôle de la sûreté et de la
radioprotection pour la protection de la
population et de l'environnement c'est
le texte de la loi qui définit notre
mission et donc qui qui ne parle pas de
prise considération d'autres d'autres
enjeux que celui là c'est notre seule
mission pour autant cette mise en
concurrence que vous évoquez vous ne
vous l'appliquez pas dans vos propres
décisions c'est à dire que vous ne
mettez pas en balance la sûreté des
installations avec la disponibilité du
parc et le besoin de production
d'électricité sur le sol français vous
privilégiez systématiquement la sûreté
des installations quelle que soit le
niveau de sûreté
c'est pas tout à fait cela en fait notre
mission c'est la sûreté donc nous
regardons la sûreté mais notre mission
c'est aussi d'avoir des décisions et
notre responsabilité d'édition
proportionnées aux enjeux donc nous
examinons la situation à chaque fois
avec un processus sur lequel je pourrais
revenir qui comporte effectivement toute
une série d'avis extérieure nous ne
sommes pas tout seul c'est l'autorité
est indépendante mais elle n'est pas
isolée ou travaillons avec toute une
série d'experts on a parlé d'irsn il y a
des groupes permanents d'experts des
consultations extérieures sommes dans un
dialogue technique avec l'exploitant
comme ça a été dit donc il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de d'échanges et ensuite il y a
une appréciation de la situation qui est
faite d'ailleurs de manière collégiale
au collège qui peut nous amener à
prendre une décision relative à la
sûreté et cette décision nous la voulons
et nous faisons en sorte qu'elle soit
proportionnées aux enjeux s'il y a un
enjeu de sûreté très élevé cette
décision elle est effectivement de
nature forte si cette si cette
proportionnalité nous conduit à
le parc si j'ose dire c'est bien ce que
vous dites simplement une décision
proportionnelle en fonction de l'enjeu
de sûreté absolument je vous remercie
j'en viens justement à la question
l'état du parc parce que on a eu
beaucoup de je crois qu'on peut le dire
comme ça de manger à l'égard de
professionnalisme et de la rigueur de la
SN simplement récemment une ancienne
ministre en charge de l'énergie a dit
qu'elle était plus inquiète pour la
sûreté des installations nucléaires
aujourd'hui qui a une vingtaine d'années
et qu'elle était même inquiète pour la
sûreté de nos installations donc comme
j'ai en face de moi le président de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire et son
directeur général je me permets de vous
poser la question sur votre état
d'inquiétude
je ne sais pas sur quoi était basé sur
son appréciation moi j'ai récemment dit
que l'état de sûreté du parc nucléaire
nous paraissait satisfaisant et que les
choses étaient en grande continuité par
rapport à ce que nous avons connu les
dernières années malgré les phénomènes
inédits qui se sont produits sur le parc
donc l'état de sûreté pas seulement
d'ailleurs des installations d'EDF mais
l'ensemble des installations du parc
nucléaire de EDF Orano et CEA nous
semble satisfaisant n'est pas de sûreté
ce que moi je dirais peut pour prendre
le contrepied de la personne qui
émettait cet avis c'est que finalement
le niveau de sûreté de nous
installations nucléaire a progresser par
rapport à celui qu'il était au moment de
leur mise en service pourquoi parce que
nous réalisons des réexamens périodiques
tous les 10 ans et nous essayons chaque
10 ans de viser un niveau de sûreté
meilleur si c'est possible pour pouvoir
améliorer le niveau de sûreté donc
contrairement à ce qu'on dit et si on
fait le parallèle avec les États-Unis
par exemple contrairement à ce que l'on
dit parfois le niveau de sûreté des
installations nucléaires françaises a
plutôt
progresser depuis leur mise en service
grâce au réexamens et au principe de
règlement que nous avons en France ce
qui n'est pas le cas aux États-Unis
ce que vous dites est très important
c'est à dire que vous battez en brèche
l'argument du parc vieillissant
c'est-à-dire qu'on utilise parfois on
entend en tout cas l'argument selon
lequel les dangers sur la sûreté
seraient plus important du fait de du
vieillissement du parc ce que vous dites
c'est que on améliore en permanence la
sûreté depuis la mise en service des
installations et que donc cette sûreté
augmente alors il y a pas que les
réexamas qui permettent cette
augmentation mais les examens il
contribue notablement lorsqu'il s'agit
de modifier la conception pour pouvoir
avoir une défense
meilleure par rapport au risque
d'accidents notamment ça c'est le cas
des réexamens mais il y a un élément qui
est fondamental dans le maintien au
niveau de sûreté c'est celui de la
maintenance qui est réalisée par par les
exploitants et qui les conduit à
entretenir leur outil industriel comme
le font tous les industriels notamment
dans les industriars risques dans une
installation nucléaire il y a énormément
d'équipements et de composants qui se
changent et ce ne sont pas les mêmes non
seulement il y a eu des réévaluations de
sûreté mais il y a plein de choses qui
ont été changées depuis 30 ans ou de 40
ans dans une installation même les
générateurs de vapeur sont chargés alors
les pompes les échangeurs plein de
choses sont changés elles sont changées
lorsque l'exploitant dans le cas de ces
programmes de contrôle et de maintenance
préventive estime qu'il faut le faire
donc l'installation nucléaire ce n'est
pas l'installation à l'identique elle
évolue constamment dans le temps et en
plus on procède à des améliorations de
sûreté de conception de sûreté à
l'occasion des réexamens et c'est pour
ça que lorsque nous nous interrogeons
sur la perspective de poursuite
d'exploitation des réacteurs ou de la 50
ou de la 60 ans nous focalisons notre
attention sur les éléments qui ne sont
pas remplaçables ou qui sont
difficilement remplaçables parce que les
autres ils seront remplacés et ça fait
partie du programme de surveillance dans
le cadre du vieillissement alors il peut
y avoir des ratés bien sûr mais c'est ça
l'objectif nous mettons en sort en
faisant en sorte que les exploitants
déterminent bien quels sont les plans de
contrôle et de maintenant ce qu'ils
doivent réaliser pour détecter les
risques de vieillissement et faire en
sorte que les il y a des modifications
et ça c'est industriellement gérable
c'est tout à fait possible les
composants non remplaçables
difficilement remplaçables ce sont
ceux-là sur lesquels il faut
s'interroger pour une perspective à plus
long terme alors justement vous évoquez
à la fois la maintenance courante si
j'ose dire et puis la question du grand
carénage mais je profite d'avoir deux
personnalités qui couvrent une large
période d'activité dans la sûreté
nucléaire pour poser quand même deux
questions rétrospectives et je vous les
pose à tous les deux en même temps la
première c'est sur la capacité à la
possibilité de mieux enfin la
possibilité rétrospectivement d'avoir
mieux anticipé le fait que l'âge des
centrales est en relativement proche on
allait avoir une superposition ou en
tout cas une simultanée ou une
superposition importante des visites
décennales et donc une indisponibilité
potentiellement forte à des moments
est-ce que vous jugez à l'aune de vos de
vos responsabilités passées et actuelles
que ce cette anticipation aurait pu être
mieux faite qu'on aurait pu avoir un
également plus important c'est une autre
manière de demander si la règle
décennale même si elle était émane d'une
direction européenne n'est pas une règle
qui pourrait être aménagée ou qui
pourrait évoluer et la deuxième question
sur la maintenance elle porte sur la
sous-traitance on a eu beaucoup de
discussions avec les anciens les
responsables anciens et actuels de DF
sur la capacité à internaliser la
sous-traitance est-ce que vous estimez
que l'éclatement des compétences au sein
de sous-traitants et le manque de
compétences qui est potentiellement
moins suivi puisque sous-traiter un lien
direct en matière de qualité du parc
d'entretien du parc et donc de sûreté
alors sur l'anticipation concernant les
examens sur terre j'ai dit tout à
l'heure
prise de position de d'EDF 2008 nous
souhaitons aller au-delà de 40 ans à
cette époque il y a 10 ans par rapport à
la première échéance de 40 ans c'est
2018 le premier acteur qui arrive à 40
ans discussion avec la SN et en 2010 on
fixé les objectifs d'un commun accord
ensuite il y a une longue période de
travail qui consiste à préparer à faire
des études à préparer leur examen et en
2011 il se produit un événement très
important c'est Fukushima qui change un
peu les données de problème puisqu'il
faut intégrer dans leur examen décennale
les suites de Fukushima donc il y a un
travail assez long de mûrissement enfin
de d'études pour pouvoir définir le
programme ce programme il est établi par
EDF discuter avec avec la SN et nous
arrivons
au début des années 2020 pour la
décision de 20 qui consiste à regarder
on a un calendrier on sait très bien
parce que les échéances de 4e visite
décennale on les connaît donc ça sera à
partir de 2018 et puis ça va se terminer
pour le dernier réacteur je lui ai donné
une date et je lui ai expliqué pourquoi
ça sera 2024 donc c'est quand même très
long ça s'étale sur beaucoup d'années de
2018 à 2034 pardon 2018 à 2034 pourquoi
est-ce que ça s'étale sur une période
aussi longue parce que nous regardons
avec EDF la question de la soutenabilité
industrielle de l'opération on définit
la nature des modifications à réaliser
et on s'aperçoit qu'effectivement avoir
un programme étalé dans le temps mais
assez chargé il faut le rendre
soutenable pour ça on définit de l'eau
c'est à dire on dit bon on va séparer en
deux groupes les modifications à
réaliser il y a un lot a qui correspond
aux modifications avec les plus forts en
jeu de sûreté qu'il faut faire au moment
de la visite des on accepte qui est un
lobé pour le deuxième niveau qui fait
dans les cinq ans qui suivent au plus
tard 5 ans qui viennent nous voyons il y
a un étalement pour répondre à votre
question de l'anticipation on est plutôt
à la fois dans l'anticipation et dans
l'étalement on tient compte des
capacités industrielles en faisant en
sorte que ça se fasse en de l'eau ce qui
fait que le Lobet du dernier réacteur je
crois que ça sera blayé 4 qui fera son
lot service décennale c'est 2034 ça
s'étale de 2018 à 2034 donc en priorise
on tient compte de la capacité
industrielle à faire
justifie bien évidemment ce qui est fait
et on fait avec suffisamment
d'anticipation pour que les industriels
de la filière soient mobilisés il y a eu
un travail remarquable qui a été fait
par EDF et pour mobiliser la filière
pour présenter le programme de travail
qui était à réaliser pendant toutes ces
années ce qui a conduit à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure à l'estimation des
charges de travail segment par segment
et un accompagnement segment par segment
pour que les industriels soient présents
nous avons demandé à EDF dans le cas de
la décision générique que nous avons
prise en 2021 de faire chaque année un
bilan de ce qui a été fait par rapport
au programme d'amélioration qui est
prévue et puis de nous signaler s'il y a
des difficultés particulières à bien
évidemment c'est des difficultés doivent
d'abord faire l'objet de mesures de
corrective aussi de la part d'EDF et
pour l'instant le bilan que nous avons
eu des opérations qui ont été faites
jusqu'à présent j'ai rappelé il y a eu
11 réacteurs qui ont déjà eu leur LOA 11
sur 32 ne montre pas de difficultés
particulières donc le programme il est
soutenable il est étalé dans le temps je
terminerai avant de donner la parole à
Olivier sur la question de la
sous-traitance par dire que il ne faut
pas confondre les modifications liées au
examen
la sous-traitance c'est d'abord un choix
de politique industriel et j'allais dire
il est parfaitement respectable il y a
des compétences pointues qui sont
détenus par un certain nombre de
d'entreprises et d'ailleurs qui sont
mieux entretenus par ces entreprises
parce qu'elles interviennent y compris
le cas échéances dans différents
secteurs d'activités pour finalement
développer mettre à profit ses
compétences et auxquelles donc les
industriels ont recours voilà donc
d'abord un choix de politique industriel
en termes de sûreté ce qui nous importe
c'est que lorsqu'il y a recours à la
sous-traitance l'exploitant qui comme je
le disais en introduction et le premier
responsable en matière de sûreté
exerce réellement son rôle de
responsable de la sûreté et donc soit en
capacité de contrôler d'abord de
spécifier ce qu'il souhaite qu'elle est
l'opération que l'entreprise prestataire
doit réaliser et ensuite soit capable de
surveiller de contrôler les opérations
et le cas échéant de nous en rendre
compte et c'est sur ce point la plupart
du temps de la surveillance des
prestataires qu'on a pu ces dernières
années constater des fragilités du côté
des DF ça a été le cas en particulier
sur la question des soudures du chantier
de l'EPR flamant ville 3 alors
d'ailleurs la fragilité elle était à la
fois sur la passation du cahier des
charges et sur la surveillance et donc
c'est très clairement un point sur
lequel EDF doit progresser et ça fait
partie effectivement de encore de nos
actions de contrôle
merci sur le parc de 3 dernières
questions d'abord une question forcément
parce que vous l'avez évoquée plusieurs
fois sur le la question du de
l'adaptation au changement climatique
pour les centrales je comprends qu'un
certain nombre de travaux sont lancés
que vous appelez de vos vœux qui sont
intégrés à la prolongation de plus de 60
ans est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner à
ce stade l'état des connaissances sur le
sujet de manière très synthétique bien
sûr et deuxièmement le l'impact que vous
que vous que vous imaginez à très court
terme avant de pouvoir rentrer dans les
travaux approfondi bien sûr qui peinent
permettront d'en savoir davantage
elle les effets potentiels du
réchauffement du dérèglement climatique
sont pris à bord si je peux prendre
cette expression dans le cadre des
réamens décédons donc ce que nous
faisons dans le cas des examen des
scénos c'est que nous révisons les aléas
notamment les agressions externes qui
sont liées aux effets de d'augmentation
de température aux effets de
tornade enfin des choses qui viennent de
l'extérieur qui sont liées au
dérèglement climatiques et nous le
faisons en réajustant à la hausse en
demandant à EDF de réajuster à la hausse
les ces aléas bien sûr en s'appuyant sur
les études notamment du GIEC qui
permettent de donner une vision à long
terme c'est plusieurs dizaines d'années
je crois que c'est de l'ordre de 30 ans
nous demandons à EDF de se projeter sur
la révision des aléas à 30 ans donc ça
c'est dans le cadre du réexamen ce que
nous disons aujourd'hui c'est que bien
sûr ça il faut continuer de le faire
mais compte tenu des perspectives d'un
nouveau programme nucléaire s'il était
décidé il faut se mettre et si la
poursuite d'exploitation des réacteurs
pouvait être elle-même être décider sur
une période plus longue que celle que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui 60 ans
peut-être 70 ans il faut il faut
regarder les choses de avec encore plus
d'anticipation et il faut le regarder de
manière globale à l'échelle des bassins
versants puisque il y a beaucoup de
sujets qui concernent l'impact du
dérèglement climatique qui concerne les
ressources en eau qui sont utilisées à
la fois pour refroidir les réacteurs
mais aussi pour comme milieu naturel
pour diluer les rejets radiologiques ou
chimiques donc il faut regarder ça de
manière globale et dans des effets de
cumul et nous voulons que cette
réflexion elle soit accolée ou adossée à
la réflexion que nous demandons à EDF de
faire sur la poursuite d'exploitation à
long terme et bien évidemment sur
l'évaluation des impacts climatiques
l'invidence d'impact climatique sur le
le
nouveau programme réacteur je vais
prendre un exemple qui est imaginons
qu'il y ait une paire de paires de sur
le Rhône
partie des options qui sont
éventuellement sur la table il y a déjà
plusieurs centrales sur sur le Rhône
certaines ont des circuits de
refroidissement ouvert c'est-à-dire que
l'eau refroidit les circuits de la
centrale et immédiatement rejeté dans le
Rhône il n'y a pas de perte en eau mais
il y a un échauffement important puis
d'autres sont équipés d'Aéro
réfrigérants donc là c'est l'inverse on
projette de l'eau avec une éluation de
température très faible voire parfois
aucune mais en revanche on perd de l'eau
à travers l'aéro réfrigérant donc à une
perte de ressources en eau mais il y a
pas d'élévation de température ou très
peu
on voit bien on a vu en 2023 en 22
pardon à l'été que nous avons été
obligés de mettre en place des
dérogations pour pouvoir assurer le
fonctionnement des centrales en
situation d'été alors jusqu'à présent
c'était assez peu une période en tension
puisque c'est en général les réacteurs
sont à l'arrêts les consommations les
besoins de l'électricité sont faibles ça
va certainement changer au fil du temps
l'électrification des usages va conduire
de toute façon même en période estivale
à avoir une forte besoin d'électricité
donc il faut
regarder finalement si tout ça est
soutenable et voir quels sont les
impacts cumulés l'impact cumulé sur le
rôle s'il y a plus de deux EP R2 qui
seront vraisemblablement équipés d'aéros
réfrigérants c'est-à-dire finalement
d'une partie d'eau qui sera rejetée à
l'atmosphère c'est qu'il va y avoir une
pression supplémentaire sur la ressource
en eau cumulée du Rhône et il y a bien
évidemment des sujets de conflit d'usage
d'autres d'autres entités nouveaux
acteurs sont eux aussi intéressés et
concernés par l'utilisation de la
ressource en eau il va y avoir aussi des
rejets qui pourraient être plus
importants de matière radioactive mais
aussi surtout chimiques parce que en
fait les aéros réfrigérants sont sujets
à développement d'amisbe et le
légionnaires et font l'objet de
traitement contre cette ce risque
sanitaire qui conduit à des rejets
chimiques en nitrates et en nitrite dans
le Rhône il y en a déjà à plusieurs
reprises il y en a une partie des
réacteurs de budget qui qui sont équipés
de Tours et réfrigérantes c'est le cas
de Cruas
c'est le cas de Saint-Alban donc il va y
avoir effectivement une accumulation de
rejets donc ce que nous voulons nous
c'est qu'on se projette dans cette dans
une vision à plus long terme qu'il ne
soit pas uniquement la question de de
la révision des aléas d'agressions
externes il faut continuer de le faire
mais il faut avoir une vision plus
globale territoriale pas tout seul c'est
pas uniquement EDF mais c'est EDF avec
les autres et il faut être capable de
voir si on peut faire évoluer même les
installations ou les inst ancienne ou
les installations nouvelles certains
évoquent des dispositifs de
refroidissement qui seraient moins
consommateurs en eau certains évoquent
des dispositifs de traitement chimiques
qui seraient moins consommateurs en
produits chimiques
et donc si c'est possible il faut le
faire il faut le faire c'est ça que nous
mettons en avant il faut le faire il
faut s'en préoccuper maintenant
je vous remercie une question deux
questions groupées sur l'aval du cycle à
la fois sur l'entreposage vous avez
plusieurs fois émis des inquiétudes
quant au retard du projet EDF à la hack
pour augmenter la capacité de
d'entreposage est-ce que vous vous avez
une idée en termes de planning des
délais qu'il faudrait tenir et
deuxièmement quel regard en tant
qu'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
portez-vous sur la potentielle le
potentiel développement d'une quatrième
génération où égard à la sûreté de ce
qu'on en connaît des réacteurs
fonctionnants dans le monde et eu égard
à l'impact que ça aurait sur la
réduction du nombre de déchets
nucléaires fin de la quantité
alors la piscine entreposage centralisé
elle avait été appelée déjà de plus de
nombreuses années dans le cadre du plan
national de gestion des déchets des
matières radioactives puisqu'il avait
été identifié que les combustibles
sortant des centrales et qui donc sont
entreposés en attente de refroidissement
dans les piscines de la Hague avant
retraitement ces cumulaient et les
piscines étaient proches de leur
saturation
le projet a pris du retard alors
aujourd'hui la situation est la suivante
nous attendons c'est ce qui est DF nous
dit un dépôt d'une demande
d'autorisation de création dans le
courant de l'année
et le planning du projet c'est
enfin c'est elle jusqu'à une mise en
service qui serait à l'horizon 2034
voilà donc ça nous garantit pas cette
date là
l'absence de risque de saturation des
piscines de la fin que les piscines de
lague ne soient pas saturées avant et
donc nous avons demandé à EDF et Orano
de réfléchir à des parades pour le cas
dans les scènes dans certains scénarios
effectivement les piscines actuelles
arriveraient à saturation avant donc
2034 il y a trois parades qui sont
regardés la densification des piscines
donc finalement mettre plus de paniers
recevant des assemblages combustibles
dans les piscines actuelles à conception
équivalente deuxième parade en parallèle
l'entreposage à sec de ces combustibles
dans des emballages en réalité de
transport
donc sur le sur le site de lag et
troisième parade c'est finalement une
autre façon de gérer le problème c'est
de retraités plus et retraités plus en
utilisant plus de MOX en réacteur donc
examiner si on peut recharger plus de
MOX dans les réacteurs DDF donc ces
trois parades sont en cours de d'examen
par les industriels on a en particulier
reçu un dossier d'option de sûreté sur
la première d'entre elles qui sont la
plus avancée qui est la densification
des piscines et qui est effectivement
qui peut permettre de
d'accommoder le sujet pendant un certain
nombre d'années ce que nous disons nous
c'est que ça ne doit en aucun cas
retarder le projet de piscine
entreposage centralisée lui-même c'est à
dire que ce sont des parades temporaires
et non pérennes
voilà sur sur la question des piscines
sur Génération 4 on avait été on avait
la SN avait été amené à regarder alors
ça devait être dans les années 2010
grosso modo
le
projet Astrid qui est qui avait été
effectivement porté à cette époque là
donc effectivement c'est cette ces
réacteur de génération 4 très clairement
ce qu'on en avait dit c'est qu'ils
doivent être au moins aussi sûr que les
réacteurs de génération 3 effectivement
ils présentent l'avantage de
d'offrir une capacité de réduction de
quantité des déchets radioactifs
notamment les plus hautement radioactifs
qui sont produits ce qui ce sur quoi il
faut être clair c'est que ça ne permet
pas de
d'aboutir à une situation où il y a
aucun déchet qui est produit les lois de
la physique font que on fait une
réaction nucléaire il y a des produits
de fission et ça on peut pas on peut pas
s'en débarrasser aussi simplement que ça
mais effectivement ça offre une
amélioration par rapport aux réacteurs
typiquement les réacteurs à ou sous
pression
de ce point de vue donc on avait été
amené à commencer l'examen d'endossier
puis effectivement ensuite le le projet
a été abandonné c'est une filière que la
France sur laquelle la France
alors a détenu et détient encore un
certain nombre de compétences
voilà en particulier s'agissant de la
filière à sodium enfin rapide à sodium
c'est moins le cas sur les autres
filières pour les femmes puisque je suis
rapide à sodium il y avait eu plusieurs
installations et la dernière d'entre
elles au super Phénix c'est moins le cas
sur les autres filières à spectre rapide
dernière question enfin dernière recette
question et après je m'en tiendrai là
sur la SN à proprement parler trois en
réalité la première vous avez évoqué la
prolongation au-delà de 60 ans et
d'ailleurs le fait de passer à des
licences ensuite à l'américaine c'est à
dire 40 60 80
aux difficultés spécifiques pour
instruire ce type de dossier est-ce que
ça nécessite des moyens supplémentaires
pour fonctionner pour votre agence la
deuxième question c'est que vous avez
évoqué hier au vœux de l'autorité
soutenucaire la question de la méthode
probabiliste plutôt que la méthode
déterminer ce que je vous laisserai
expliquer mieux que moi mais simplement
ne pas forcément envisager ce qui se
passe pour chaque scénario considérer
que chaque risque va se réaliser et
comment on réduit cette les impacts mais
réfléchir en probabilité et savoir ça
peut faire gagner du temps et de la
rentabilité et puis troisième question
sur la plus prospective sur l'intérêt la
pertinence d'avoir pour la SN des moyens
supplémentaires ou d'avoir une logique
de partenariat pour pouvoir instruire
très en amont des projets de R&D ou de
démonstrateurs de nouvelles technologies
nucléaires qui permettraient de gagner
du temps par rapport au procédures
classiques c'est-à-dire d'instructions
sur la base d'un système fonctionnant
tout d'abord sur le pas de temps donc
hier effectivement j'ai
illustré la nécessité selon la SN
d'avoir en parallèle pour examen des
scénos une vision long terme
avec le fait que les Américains ont un
pas de temps qui n'est pas celui de 10
ans mais de 20 ans et donc ça permet
effectivement en réfléchissant à
réfléchissant à 20 ans en fonction de la
décision qui est prise ou de
anticiper les conséquences ce qui n'est
pas possible dans un système nucléaire
ou les constructions nouvelles en termes
de conception et de réalisation sont de
toute façon sur un pas d'au moins 15 ans
il faut 15 ans pour faire quelque chose
de nouveau en France à ne parler de la
piscine centralisée mais c'est pareil
pour les réacteurs donc si on réfléchit
tous les 10 ans et qu'au bout de 10 ans
on dit bah non finalement ce réacteur on
peut pas le continuer on est on est déjà
trop tard c'est déjà trop tard donc pour
pouvoir pouvoir anticiper il faut avoir
un pas de temps différent mais je ne
souhaite pas que nous changeons notre
part l'idée n'est pas d'avoir un passé
d'un pas de dix ans à 20 ans il faut de
mon point de vue conserver le pas de 10
ans parce qu'il y a plein de sujets qui
sont à l'échelle des 10 ans notamment
les détections de vieillissement
n'oublions pas que la corrosion sous
contrainte a été détectée à l'occasion
de contrôle qui ont été faits non pas
pour la corrosion sous contratte et pour
la fatigue thermique mais à l'occasion
des visites décennales si on avait
attendu 20 ans
la corrosion sous contrainte ce serait
encore propagé pendant 10 ans et
peut-être qu'on aurait eu une accident
donc il vaut mieux faire un examen tous
les 10 ans et puis s'interroger sur la
possibilité d'améliorer la sûreté
ponctuellement sur certains sujets tous
les 10 ans parce que c'est le
cadencement industriel qui le permet
donc on ne va pas lâcher le système que
nous avons qui me paraît adapté mais il
est pas adapté à la perspective de long
terme en fait quand on regarde tous les
10 ans on est un peu en régime établi on
est on est dans une espèce de tuyau et
tous les 10 ans je regarde tous les 10
km on regarde mais on ne se préoccupe
pas si un jour le tuyau a une fin et ça
c'est très important de le savoir avec
suffisamment d'anticipation de 10 à 20
ans donc on va faire les deux en
parallèle on fait le réexamen pour toute
l'installation et sur les quelques
composants c'est pas on va pas prendre
position sur on peut faire fonctionner
ce réacteur à 60 ans ou à 70 ans on va
regarder si les quelques éléments
sensibles
identifiés comme un accord avec EDF et
l'IRSN qui sont irremplaçables ou
difficilement remplaçable avec les
méthodes de justification que nous avons
aujourd'hui jusqu'au ça peut aller de
manière raisonnable on va regarder ça
s'agit pas de consommer les marges il
s'agit de regarder de manière
raisonnable jusqu'où ça peut aller parce
que eDF n'a pas fait l'exercice jusqu'à
présent lorsque l'on a instruit le
quatrième examen des réacteurs de 900 MW
EDF a justifié jusqu'à 50 ans la tenue
de la cuve parce que c'était l'exercice
d'avoir un pas de temps de 10 ans ce que
nous disons
par robuste n'est pas réaliste lorsqu'on
est dans une question qui concerne le
long terme donc c'est ce que nous allons
faire on va conserver le pas mais on va
faire un examen supplémentaire est-ce
que ça a demandé des moyens à la SN pour
un sur tout ça bien sûr on est dans une
situation qui est extrêmement tendue en
matière de ressources quand on voit la
somme des sujets
prolongation nouveau parc SMS
on a un nombre un nombre inédit de
sujets et de construction nouvelle
construction semble piscine centralisée
Georges Besse 2 etc c'est considérable
donc on a besoin de moyens et je
j'espère bien que les parlementaires
nous aideront à convaincre le
gouvernement de nous en donner davantage
donc on a vraiment un sujet de moyens
en ce qui concerne la méthode
en ce qui concerne les méthodes qui sont
qui sont utilisées il s'agit pas de
s'opposer la question est-ce qu'on va
accepter une méthode prendre une
approche probabilité ou pas illustrer le
propos de la différence de méthode à
travers cet exemple qui est assez simple
il va les Américains ont une approche
probabiliste ils acceptent finalement
des situations qui sont à très faibles
probabilité d'occurrence alors que nous
nous n'acceptons pas ces situations nous
regardons en profondeur de la situation
c'est un une manière d'illustrer la
différence de méthode mais il y a
beaucoup de convergences dans les
méthodes que nous avons avec les
Américains au départ frontalement
frontalement opposés mais dans les
méthodes de justification il y a plein
de petits paramètres qui qui sont en
compte finalement quel est quel est
l'état de sollicitation de la structure
tout ça ça se modélise
quelles sont les caractéristiques
mécaniques de des matériaux ça se ça
s'évalue ça s'estime donc aujourd'hui on
peut penser qu'avec le résultat de la
recherche ou de l'expérience à
l'étranger peut-être que les les
paramètres qui sont utilisés dans les
méthodes de justification que nous avons
en France peut-être peuvent être
révisées il faut s'interroger sur sur
cette question on peut avoir toute une
débat sur les nouvelles méthodes mais ce
que je souhaite c'est qu'on le fasse de
manière séquentée c'est-à-dire que l'on
regarde dans un premier temps ce que
j'ai appelé le point zéro on regarde
avec les méthodes de justification
actuelle jusqu'où ces composants
sensibles pourraient-ils raisonnablement
être maintenu pour poursuivre
l'exploitation des installations dès
lors que on arrive
une impasse ou une difficulté la
question c'est finalement est-ce que les
méthodes de justification que nous
utilisons aujourd'hui peuvent évoluer et
ce cette évolution il faut le regarder à
travers l'expérience acquise en France
les travaux de recherche réalisés en
France mais aussi l'expérience faite à
l'étranger se comparer et puis à ce
moment-là ce que je souhaite c'est que
EDF nous propose des évolutions des
méthodes il s'agit pas de les dérouler
tout de suite il s'agit de les pour
qu'on puisse les expertiser débattre et
dire celles-ci oui éventuellement
celle-là moyen dentelle modification oui
et puis celle-là non peut-être que
l'approche probabiliste sera une
approche que nous considérerons comme
n'étant pas approprié à la situation
française mais on a acceptera
vraisemblablement d'autres sujets donc
il y a un point d'arrêt sur quels sont
les évolutions des méthodes actuelles
qu'il faudrait considérer puis ensuite
il faut les dérouler pour avoir un
résultat pour pouvoir prendre position
c'est ça le processus et puis il y a des
spécificités qu'il faut prendre en
compte dans le parc français qui ne sont
pas les spécificités nécessairement
présentes aux États-Unis je pense qu'il
y a le la question du fonctionnement en
suivi de charge est importante on ne
sait pas si elle a un effet ou pas
peut-être elle en a-t-elle pas sur la la
durée de vie mais peut-être en attelle
et cette ce suivi de charge va
s'accentuer dans les années à venir du
fait que finalement la production
d'électricité nucléaire avec
l'hydraulique sera la seule source de
pilotable donc il faudra effectivement
la faire varier la puissance des
réacteurs quasiment continue par
continue mais c'est plus souvent que
maintenant quel impact ça doit avoir
donc il faut et travailler sur ces
sujets là il faut peut-être faire un peu
de recherche un peu d'essai il faut
comprendre et on peut pas regarder ce
qui se passe aux États-Unis puis ils ne
sont pas dans cette situation là donc on
a des sujets propres sur lesquels il
faut travailler c'est tout cela que nous
souhaitons voir pris en charge par EDF
d'ici fin 2024 pour que on est fin 2024
des éléments complets sur ces composants
sensibles ou ses effets et fait du suivi
de charge et fait du réchauffement
climatique pour que nous puissions
prendre une position après instruction
fin 2026 et la position que nous
prendrons ce sera pas une décision bah
oui les réacteurs peuvent fonctionner
on décide tout de suite jusqu'à 80 ans
ce sera quelque chose qui permettra de
dire sur les composants que nous avons
étudié les méthodes de justification
actuellement nouvelles permettent
d'envisager que ou elles peuvent être
révis pour etc donc ce sera un avis qui
sera certainement en nuance pas un avis
oui ou non
justement sur ces questions méthodes
enfin les méthodes elles évoluent en
fait assez régulièrement les méthodes
d'études d'accident en particulier elles
ont évolué à plusieurs reprises depuis
depuis l'origine que ce soit à
l'initiative de l'exploitant qui
souhaite justement enfin faire prendre
en compte dans ces méthodes un élément
qui qui est plus favorable ou Laurent en
général plutôt à notre initiative ou à
celle de l'IRSN lorsque à l'inverse il y
a une connaissance nouvelle qui
nécessite d'être incluse et qui le cas
échéant au contraire à des effets on va
dire moins favorables donc ça se ça se
fait et ça se fait j'allais dire à
chaque fois son concession au plan de la
sûreté mais mais c'est la c'est c'est
bien la logique deuxième point sur
lesquels je souhaitais aussi
intervenir c'est sur la question des
études probabilise de sûreté il y a
naturellement des études probabilisent
sûreté en France et donc la vérification
de la sûreté des installations
nucléaires en particulier des centrales
nucléaires elle repose à la fois sur des
méthodes déterministes
on postule des accidents et on regarde
on déroule et on regarde comment ça se
passe mais elle repose aussi
conjointement sur des des probabilités
des évaluations probabilités et ça
depuis déjà un bon moment donc il y a
pas de nouveautés là-dedans
par contre effectivement le débat que
vous soulevez c'est jusqu'à quel point
on se repose le cas échéant
exclusivement sur un seuil de coupure en
matière de probabilité et là
effectivement sur des composants
supposés non ruptibles c'est à dire pour
lesquelles les conséquences de la
rupture ne sont pas prises en compte et
ne sont pas gérés par des systèmes qui
permettent de la compenser effectivement
c'est là que voilà le débat enfin de
notre point de vue le sujet est plus
questionnable
là dessus là aussi un point qui me
paraît extrêmement fondamental c'est que
il y a toutes les procédures qui sont
visibles
les dossiers d'options de sûreté les
demandes d'autorisation de création les
autorisations de mise en service les
procédures réglementaires en fait
appelés par la réglementation mais en
amont tout ça il y a énormément de
dialogues dès le et très en amont ça a
été le cas d'ailleurs sur tous les
grands projets
nous interroger sur les projets nouveaux
là mais c'est déjà le cas sur les grands
projets franchement je prends l'exemple
de 6Go c'est aussi le cas de l'EPR des
flamants ville 3 mais aussi surpr2 on a
dialogué avec les industriels très en
amont de ces procédures on va dire
réglementaires et un peu plus formel ce
qui fait que d'ailleurs quand les
dossiers sont déposés il y a déjà
beaucoup de choses en fait qui sont
traitées par ces discussions en amont
alors naturellement pour l'instruction
de ces nouveaux projets de réacteur
s'agissant de technologie innovantes
pour certaines qui ne sont pas les
technologies bien connues
de notre part qui sont les les
technologies à vos sous-pression il y
aura besoin d'une instruction aussi très
en amont avec des porteurs de projets un
point sur lequel on attire l'attention
aussi c'est que il s'agit pas seulement
de discuter sur les projets de réacteurs
eux-mêmes il s'agit de discuter sur
l'ensemble réacteur et combustible cycle
du combustible puisque s'agissant de
finalement de des projets qui ne sont
pas des réacteurs à eau sous pression il
y aura besoin de fabriquer un
combustible spécifique qui n'est pas
aujourd'hui fabriqué en France qui n'est
pas retraité ou retraitable
nécessairement dans les usines
existantes de la Hague donc ça ça doit
être discuté aussi pour pas se retrouver
dans des impasses finalement avoir une
machine qui a prouvé un combustible
usé finalement dont on sait pas que
faire parce qu'on n'a pas prévu les
moyens de de le gérer après
très bien pour le groupe Renaissance je
sais pas
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
tout d'abord de façon très triviale dire
que la France peut s'engueillir d'avoir
une autorité de sûreté nucléaire
indépendante et exigeante alors mes
questions première question concerne la
corrosion sous contrainte en fait la
prise en compte par EDF il semble qu'il
y a une réaction rapide et de la part
des des équipes de DF pour identifier le
problème pour mettre en place un système
de de test de détection améliorées et
donc une prise en compte rapide et
transparente qui a donné lieu bien sûr à
certaines décisions dont l'arrêt
temporaire de réacteur
alors il avait été annoncé des remises
en route de réacteurs à au mois de
septembre en fait ça s'est fait en
décalé donc je voulais savoir si c'était
pour des raisons techniques
d'autorisation par la ou bien si c'est
un manque de ressources enfin voilà
c'est une question
assez basique également
ensuite concernant le Pr
[Musique]
out les
problématiques de gestion de projet qui
n'étaient visiblement pas
à niveau
lorsque les problèmes se sont enchaînés
en série est-ce que de votre point de
vue il y a des choix techniques
qui engendrent des difficultés
on a sous-entendu parler des des
vibrations dans les paniers de
combustible ou autre mais des choix
techniques qui nécessitent d'être vu à
ces fondamentalement pour le PR2
troisième question sur le cycle
la France à cette singularité de de
retraités les déchets ce qui permet un
compactage des déchets mais aussi
d'avoir cette filière MOX est-ce que
vous la jugez suffisamment robuste
aujourd'hui en terme de sûreté par
rapport à
aux événements concernant l'usine de
Melox et autres
j'avais aussi des questions
effectivement sur le cycle Laval sur et
sur les les réacteurs à neutrons rapide
quelles sont les spécificités en matière
de sûreté concernant la filière à sodium
et lorsque vous parliez de filière à
spectre rapide différentes est-ce que
vous faisiez référence aux combustible à
celle fondue et là à nouveau quels sont
les spécificités
en matière de de sûreté si on se
projette un peu dans l'avenir merci
alors
d'abord sur la corrosion sous contrainte
donc je
le répète ici parce que c'est important
c'est c'est un sujet sérieux et c'est un
sujet qui a été traité très sérieusement
par EDF c'était un phénomène totalement
inattendu à cet endroit là du réacteur
et contenu des matériaux utilisés pour
fabriquer les tuyauteries et il y avait
pas de retour d'expérience
internationale ça ne s'était produit
nulle part ailleurs donc c'est vraiment
un sujet sérieux compte tenu de la
taille des fissurations qui pouvaient
qui pourrait dans un certain nombre de
cas conduire à des ruptures de cette
ligne de d'injection de sécurité en cas
de déclenchement et conduire à un
accident une situation accidentelle donc
c'est en termes de proportionnalité
c'est c'est sérieux c'était sérieux et
dès la découverte fortuite du du de la
corrosion sous contrainte EDF a réagi
vraiment immédiatement en première
responsable de la sûreté on décidant
d'aller voir sur les mêmes réactifs de
réacteurs qui étaient à l'arrêt et de ne
pas hésiter à faire des découpes et donc
forcément immobilisé des réacteurs parce
qu'il n'y avait aucun moyen de contrôle
à l'époque au moment où on découvre le
phénomène il y a aucun moyen de contrôle
non destructif permettant de
caractériser la taille des fissurations
sans faire de déco ça ça a été fait sur
une série de réacteurs une douzaine
pendant le premier semestre 2022 et ça
et c'était indispensable pour comprendre
le phénomène pour vérifier l'état des
réacteurs et pouvoir avoir une une
justification qui qui permettent
d'établir une stratégie
en juillet 2022 au vu des travaux qui
avaient été faits des analyses EDF a
proposé une stratégie de priorisation
que nous avons accepté puisque
finalement
l'analyse qui a été menée conduisait à
identifier 16 réacteurs les quatre
réacteurs du palier N4 et 12 réacteurs
du sous-palier P prime 4 directeur de
1300 Mo comme étant susceptible d'être
les plus affectés les autres réacteurs
donc c'est quand même 16 sur 56 donc
quand même 40 réacteurs qui étaient jugé
moins moins affectés
nous n'avons à aucun moment du processus
était un élément
retardateur de ce qu'a fait EDF EDF a
bien évidemment au titre de
l'application de la réglementation a été
obligée de demander l'accord de la SF
pour réaliser un certain nombre d'étapes
des découpes des nouvelles soudures etc
et à aucun moment nous n'avons été un
élément qui a retardé le planning ce qui
a retardé le plus au démarrage le
processus c'est la disponibilité
industrielle avoir des équipes en nombre
suffisant de d'opérateurs et de soudeur
qualifiés d'avoir des matières premières
EDF a aussi très réagit très rapidement
en
s'assurant d'approvisionnement notamment
de pièces qui étaient fabriquées à
l'étranger mais rapidement ça a été fait
et il y a eu ensuite des équipes de
soudeur qui ont dû être qualifiés
l'opération est en étant pas simple
puisque elle se réalise dans une
installation qui est déjà en service
donc il y a beaucoup d'encombrement
autour des beaucoup d'autres choses
autour des canalisations à des tuyaux à
reprendre et puis il y a des soudures à
réaliser qui sont compliquées donc
vraiment il y avait un difficulté
industrielle qui a été je commence
maintenant résolu mais qui a retardé
les chantiers puisqu'il y avait eu des
il fallait réparer donc c'est de mon
point de vue la cause principale de
l'étalement des des chantiers même si il
y en a d'autres mais celle là est
vraiment la cause principale et à aucun
moment la SN n'a été un frein dans le
roulement du projet aujourd'hui on est
devant une
stratégie qui consiste à
réparer
proposition d'EDF à réparer les lignes
les plus affectées sur les réacteurs
petrin 4 il y a autant que j'ai dit 16
réacteurs sur les 16 il y en a 7 qui ont
déjà fait l'objet de réparation parce
que c'était des réacteurs qui étaient
dans la période d'investigation qui
avait été mise à l'arrêt pour
investigation donc ils ont été contrôlés
puis réparés 7 il y en a trois qui sont
encore en cours de contrôle
éventuellement de réparation et il y en
a 6 qui seront contrôlés d'ici fin 2023
parce que ce nous avons accepté la
proposition d'EDF de faire le contrôle
et surtout les réparations puisque
maintenant EDF a décidé systématiquement
de réparer indépendamment d'ailleurs de
la phase contrôle mais à l'occasion des
arrêts programmés donc on ne met pas à
l'arrêt les réacteurs on attend que leur
arrêt programmé pour faire les
réparations donc ça ça change de
beaucoup la situation puisque les seules
réacteurs qui avaient été à l'arrêt
forcé du fait des découpes ont été
maintenant réparés et sont mis en place
donc on est sur une programmation avec
peut-être certains arrêts qui sont un
peu plus longs que prévu puisqu'il va il
faudra faire les opérations voilà en ce
qui concerne la corrosion sous
contrainte
alors le père y a-t-il des choix
techniques qui pourraient justifier le
retard dans le projet je pense qu'il y a
il faut distinguer si vous voulez les
choix de conception initiaux et puis ce
qui s'est passé en termes de retour
d'expérience sur la famille des epops
alors les choix de conception initiaux
on sait que la complexité de l'EPR et le
rapport de Jean-Martin Falck le met bien
en évidence et du chaud lié au
finalement à la manière dont le projet
avait été imaginé au départ c'est à dire
de faire un projet franco-allemand en
prenant le meilleur des deux mondes
alors le meilleur des deux mondes c'est
pas forcément d'abord c'était différent
de ce qui existait dans chacun des mots
et c'est pas forcément plus facile donc
il y a eu une combinaison de de
conception qui allemande sur les
réacteurs qu'on voie avec la conception
française et ça ça conduit à un réacteur
un peu compliqué à construire en plus
des défaillances de gestion de projet
sur lesquels je ne reviens pas donc du
point de vue des choix techniques la
difficulté majeure c'est effectivement
d'avoir fait une tête de série avec un
réacteur qui était d'une conception
différente des précédentes a été un
mariage de de de générations
technologiques avec
longtemps une perte du partenaire
allemand donc il a fait gérer tout seul
des choix qui avaient été réalisés à
deux ensuite il y a le retour
d'expérience de ce qui s'est passé
ailleurs et ça ça fonctionne plutôt bien
c'est à dire que finalement le retour
d'expérience de ce qui s'est passé à
païenshan de même donc il auto en termes
de construction d'essai qui ont été
réalisés sur au kiloto a permis de
revenir sur un certain nombre de de
conception qui avait été faite pour le
père de Flamanville donc il y a eu des
questions de ligne qui vibrait donc il y
avait des questions de vibration ça
c'est aucune auto qui ont permis sur des
lignes d'expansion du pressuriseur à
faire évoluer la conception et puis il y
a le retour d'expérience de tyshan qui
est lié aux vibrations qui sont dans le
cœur du réacteur qui est lié aux
assemblages combustibles pour lequel
l'EDF a fait un retour d'expérience avec
les Chinois extrêmement approfondis sur
lequel nous sommes nous sommes d'accord
et à proposer un certain nombre de
modifications certaines vont être mises
en place dès la un service de le père de
Flamanville et d'autres des évolutions
de conception seront un peu différés
mais le retour d'expérience marche bien
donc là l'évolution de la conception
elle tient compte et c'est naturel et ça
a toujours été comme ça elle tient
compte en fait du retour d'expérience de
la mise en service de la tête de série
et là on bénéficie certaines manières de
la tête de série de fonctionnement qui
est celle de la Chine puisque le
réacteur européen de favoris n'est pas
en service
je sais pas si tu veux répondre sur les
cycles et sur la balle là aussi le choix
du retraitement c'est clairement un
choix de politique
énergétique au sens large notre
responsabilité à nous coûter SN c'est de
vérifier la sûreté afin de contrôler la
sûreté des installations du cycle
la radio protection des travailleurs
dans ces installations la protection
environnement au sens les rejettes ces
installations et puis bien entendu
finalement de vérifier qu'il n'y a pas
d'impasse en lien avec le fonctionnement
de ceci d'un passe qui pourrait
justement avoir des conséquences en
matière de sûreté de gestion des déchets
par exemple
et donc une idée de protection des
personnes et de l'environnement le point
de vigilance actuelle vous l'avez cité
c'est l'usine de Melox
puisque en fait sa capacité de
fabrication de combustible MOX a été
très largement diminué ces dernières
années et donc ça a contribué au sujet
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure qui est
gorgement déficit de la puisque quand on
peut pas sortir les combustibles pour
retraitement et bien effectivement il
s'accumulent donc Orano a pris des
mesures alors c'était lié cette
difficulté un changement de technologie
dans la fabrication de la poudre qui est
en entrée de de cette usine et qui est
cette usine en fait prendre la poudre
pour en constituer ensuite des pastilles
qui sont ensuite
introduites dans les assemblages de
combustible
une nouvelle technologie de fabrication
de la poudre a été mise en oeuvre
et il semble que depuis quelques mois
elle donne des résultats meilleurs donc
la capacité de fabrication de l'usine
Melox c'est améliorée elle n'est pas
revenue aujourd'hui à la normale pour
autant donc des progrès sont attendus
mais
le la tendance est plutôt à
l'amélioration
et puis sur sur ce que vous avez appelé
Laval
filière à sodium filière à selle fondue
alors j'ai évoqué l'expérience française
en matière de
réacteurs rapides à sodium avec en
particulier super Phénix alors ça c'est
une filière sur laquelle nous
bénéficions d'un certain même si les
unités retours d'éclairdiens
d'expérience pour autant le sodium pose
un certain nombre de difficultés
intrinsèques alors il y a la réactivité
du sodium face à l'eau le fait que le
sodium peut s'enflammer au contact y
compris de l'air
le fait que il est opaque au rayonnement
donc quand on veut contrôler des
tuyauteries remplis de sodium ben c'est
compliqué puisque on n'a pas en fait la
même possibilité que quand ces
tuyauteries sont remplis d'eau voilà ce
quelques exemples que je cite
après il y a évidemment l'avantage du
spectre rapide c'est-à-dire la capacité
à mieux utiliser le combustible et
finalement
à mieux gérer les déchets sur les selles
fondues il y a beaucoup moins de retours
d'expérience donc là je serai plus en
peine de vous faire
un tableau des avantages et des
inconvénients de cette filière je pense
que la plus grande difficulté en lien
avec cette filière c'est effectivement
d'arriver à
redémarrer alors il y a eu il y a eu des
prototypes ou des prototypes dans les
années 50 mais voyez ça date c'est pas
forcément d'ailleurs avec tout à fait
les mêmes technologies et notamment les
mêmes types de celles que ce qui est
envisagé aujourd'hui
et donc c'est tout ça qui est à rebâtir
y compris en termes de compétences
d'ailleurs pour nous-mêmes et pour
l'URSS mais naturellement pour les les
porteurs de projets
merci beaucoup madame cousin
oui et bien merci messieurs de d'être
venu jusqu'à nous nous expliquer tout
cela je vais j'ai quelques questions
mais je crois que vous avez répondu
partiellement
à mes questions déjà donc c'était à
propos de la capacité de former les
personnes que nous
aurions donc dans nos aurions besoin
vous parliez d'une génération et ça ne
me paraît beaucoup pour avoir
des personnes formées compétentes dans
ce domaine là afin d'avoir le nombre
nécessaire pour pour avoir autant de
personnes que nécessaire donc
la longueur de la durée de la révision
n'est-il pas dû au manquement justement
de personnels compétents dans ces
domaines et ne faut-il pas envisager
peut-être un plan Marshall cohérent pour
ne pas toujours innover mais multiplier
plutôt les forces et donc trouver des
solutions et en matière justement de de
recyclage n'y a-t-il pas possibilité de
retrouver notamment dans le projet
Astrid abandonner des solutions pour
qu'il répond à la réduction des déchets
et on pourrait peut-être développer tout
de même ce secteur là pour pour trouver
des solutions sachant que il va aussi
manquer de l'eau moi je suis à
demi-heure de la centrale nucléaire de
Golfech et je sais que cet été l'eau à
poser souci donc ça va devenir un réel
problème
urgemment
merci
la question des ressources alors je j'ai
dit je le confirme que pour moi
l'attractivité de la filière et le
recrutement des dans tous les niveaux
d'écoles blancs au col bleu comme on dit
et vraiment le défi numéro 1 pour
pouvoir faire face au programme
extrêmement ambitieux qui va s'étaler
sur de nombreuses années quand j'ai
parlé des faits sur une génération c'est
que bien évidemment les projets il y en
a qui vont démarrer immédiatement mais
ça va s'étaler si les perspectives qui
sont annoncées sont finalement acceptées
au moins jusqu'en 2050 voire plus donc
ça va s'étaler sur de très nombreuses
années et il y aura pendant cette
période là de temps il y aura des gens
qui vont partir qui sont aujourd'hui
dans la filière qui sont chez
exploitants qui vont partir et donc
c'est ça il va y avoir en continu d'une
certaine manière le besoin de de
compléter les ressources par de nouveaux
entrants et ça va prendre de mon point
de vue facilement le temps d'une
génération et cette génération en tout
cas pour le
première étape elle est déjà là c'est
celle qui est il y a un certain nombre
de de personnes qui sont déjà dans les
entreprises mais les nouveaux entrants
dans le dispositif et ils sont dans le
dans le circuit de formation à la fois
professionnel ou supérieur ou
scientifique et c'est cette
génération-là qui va falloir attirer
vers les métiers du nucléaire et c'est
pas c'est pas gagné ça ne se décrète pas
ce n'est pas parce que il y aura un
grand programme électro-nucléaire qui va
y avoir automatiquement des choix de la
part des des jeunes entrants qui ont les
filières adéquates pour dire oui moi je
vais aller vers le nucléaire donc c'est
c'est compliqué et puis dans le
nucléaire il faut distinguer les métiers
qui ne sont pas les mêmes il y a des
métiers d'ingénierie qui sont des
métiers plutôt de de
en équipe qui sont sur des des
plateformes enfin des plateaux et qui
comportent des ressources adaptées des
outils très spécifiques aux études
ingénierie
et puis il y a des gens qui fabriquent
des composants non usine qui sont pas du
tout dans le même stress que ceux qui
sont sur le site ils ont un
environnement industriel ils peuvent
s'organiser ils ont leur famille à
proximité
c'est gérable on peut organiser ça et
dans un bassin d'emploi pour pouvoir
recruter pour lui et puis il y a ceux
qui sont des sur les sites et ça c'est
très différent l'attractivité du métier
sur site c'est très spécifique c'est
plus compliqué il y a des ruptures de
charges les gens on parle souvent de
temps soudage qui est très faible parce
qu'il y a une co-activité
c'est très compliqué donc il faut avoir
des gens qui soient éloignés de chez eux
qui vivent un peu comme des nomades
c'est pas facile dans le contexte actuel
de vision de des conditions de travail
de d'attirer des gens sur des nomades et
les chantiers c'est les chantiers c'est
là où on construit on fait pas ça on va
pas faire des réacteurs en
usine il y a des gros composants mais
donc voyez-vous il faut vraiment
regarder tous les métiers
toutes les configurations segments par
segment et donc il y a un travail en
profondeur il faut embarquer l'éducation
nationale il faut embarquer les
collectivités territoriales il faut que
l'État travaille bon il y a plein de
choses et j'ai moi-même utilisé le
l'expression plan Marshall et il y a
plusieurs mois d'ailleurs en disant il
faut un véritable port Marshall parce
que c'est vraiment un plan de reconquête
industrielle comme l'avait été le plan
Marshall voilà donc voilà donc il y a
vraiment un sujet de génération et il
faut ça prendra du temps je suis
convaincu peut-être même plus d'une
génération
je pense que c'est aux industriels de
déjà de décider quel projet ils veulent
réaliser et nous naturellement et c'est
ce qu'on fait y compris avec les
porteurs de projets de type SMS ou Mr
réacteur avancé petit réacteur avancé on
se tient à leur disposition et on en
fait on a engagé y compris des à présent
des discussions avec ces porteurs de
projets on a des discussions sur un
projet de réacteur assez le fondu on a
des discussions sur naturellement un
projet de petit réacteur à ou sous
pression d'ignoire etc on a des
discussions avec les porteurs de projets
merci beaucoup monsieur Bex je profite
de l'occasion pour lui souhaiter la
bienvenue dans notre commission
d'enquête puisqu'il vient de la
rejoindre et bien bonjour à tous merci
pour le mode bienvenue monsieur le
Président et Monsieur directeur général
de l'Autorité de sûreté de sûreté
nucléaire donc la sûreté auprès de la
population des populations et de
l'environnement faut jamais l'oublier
vous êtes là pour protéger les
populations donc lourdes responsabilité
sur un domaine complexe nucléaire à une
industrie qui a été décidé dans les
années 70 et qui maintenant il faut
gérer l'héritage donc j'ai surtout
retenu de votre intervention sur les
marges de production vous nous alertez
sur les marges de production
qu'on a pas assez de marge de production
au niveau du nucléaire et donc ça peut
mettre en cause des risques forcément vu
c'est abordé changement climatique le
manque d'eau dans les cours d'eau
justement pour refroidir les centrales
les la maintenance s'est abordé aussi la
de la corrosion sous contrainte qui
nécessite justement une maintenance qui
est plus appuyée comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure la sûreté est plus forte
qu'elle n'existait avant parce que là on
a une expertise il y a une expérience
donc c'est un nécessite une plus grande
surveillance et du coup et du coup bah
forcément bah tous les réacteurs on l'a
vu cette année c'est remonté à la
surface je veux dire le sujet sur les
centrales avec le changement climatique
la sécheresse et ben oui notre parc
notre parc de 53 je ne tiens 53
réacteurs ils étaient pas tous en état
mais moi je voudrais prendre je voudrais
vous poser la question sur sur en fait
la fin du cycle du nucléaire vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure vous avez prononcé
trois fois le mot si géo centre
industriel géologique
qui est en pour l'instant en discussion
je veux dire et je reviens sur les
piscines de lague ou on entrepose des
déchets radioactifs je rappelle que le
son du sujet il est prévu pour enfuir
les déchets radioactifs
je crois et qui représente aussi à 99 %
de la radioactivité un chantier que même
mes arrières petits-enfants ne
renverront pas la fin je veux dire c'est
on va creuser
ce chantier et on va en fuir des déchets
donc moi je voulais avoir votre avis
parce que là c'était vraiment abordé
très très succinctement votre avis vous
en tant que autorité de sûreté nucléaire
qui est le plus gros chantier que qu'on
n'est jamais fait dans j'irai même dans
l'histoire de l'humanité je veux dire ce
qui va se passer à Bures c'est en
pourparler façon négociation rien n'est
fait rien n'est fait donc moi je
voudrais avoir votre éclairage sur on va
dire la fin enfin du nucléaire parce
qu'on parle des piscines de lag mais
après qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ces
déchets sans parler du des nouvelles du
nouvel du nouveau VPN que on parle de
Flamanville mais aussi comme vous l'avez
dit les marges de production et là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait concrètement avec
des marges de production qui sont très
limites qui sont vous avez alerté est-ce
qu'on est on risque pas de mettre en
danger justement les populations en
disant ben là on est limite mais au
niveau sûreté nucléaire voilà c'est la
tension que vous en tant qu'autorité sur
tes nucléaire vous devez avoir dans ces
cas-là et qu'elle serait pour vous vos
recommandations parce que là c'est dans
les 15 20 ans quoi je veux dire parce
que si jamais on
renouvelle notre part où il y a des
nouveaux VPN c'est pas demain quoi
l'urgence elle est là au niveau de
l'énergie et au niveau des besoins
électriques qu'on a actuellement en
France
la parole on va s'adapter
progressivement à nos style respectifs
on essaye de poser des questions plutôt
que de posséder des postulats mais c'est
le propre de l'exercice de la commission
d'enquête monsieur le Président
je vais répondre sur la le premier sujet
et puis je laisserai Olivier ta réponse
sur le sujet Suisseo et le stockage de
déchets géologique alors sur le sur le
sujet alors effectivement vous vous
confierez vous avez bien je crois
pointer le fait que la question
principale que nous soulevons c'est
celle de disposer de marge suffisante
dans la production
du système électrique pour que il n'y
ait pas un risque de mise en conflit de
l'intérêt général d'avoir de
l'électricité par rapport à l'intérêt
général d'assurer le fonctionnement des
installations nucléaires en toute sûreté
c'est un sujet que nous avons souligné
depuis très nombreuses années plus de 10
ans c'est un sujet qui à l'évidence n'a
pas été entendu
en 2003 en 2013 pardon les alertes
faites par les ASN non me semble-t-il
pas conduit à d'action particulière pour
pouvoir assurer
des marges suffisantes dans le système
électrique
je ne sais pas pourquoi je n'étais pas
présent mais forcé de constater que face
aux événements que nous connaissons que
nous avons connu cette cet hiver il y a
eu certainement plein d'autres décisions
ça ne concernait pas que le nucléaire
mais qui ont conduit à une tension sur
les capacités de production électrique
toute filière confondues toutes filières
confondues alors vous évoquez la
question de finalement de la fin puisque
vous dites mais oui mais tout ça aura
une fin et je pense que c'est vraiment
je n'ai pas indiqué tout à l'heure c'est
vraiment ce qui nous gouverne quand nous
disons il faut non seulement travailler
sur les marges ça ça va prendre du temps
je suis d'accord avec vous il y a une
période
des dix années ou 15 années qui viennent
ou finalement il va falloir compter sur
autre chose que la production nucléaire
nouvelle il y aura pas de réacteur
nucléaire nouveau dans les dans les
13-15 ans qui viennent donc il faudra
bien récupérer un certain nombre de
marges et de capacité de production
une autre manière de notre manière
ensuite la question de indépendamment de
la question de la marche c'est la
question de l'anticipation parce que
tout à l'heure on parlait de on parlait
de la durée d'exploitation du parc du
clair actuel
on peut de on verra bien mais il y a une
chose qui est certaine c'est que Sora
une fin ça ne va pas éternellement
continuer et cette fin je ne sais pas
quand est-ce qu'elle se produira mais
elle se produira vraisemblablement quand
on peut penser après l'horizon 2050
et à ce moment là elle va en danger une
courte période si on imagine que la
quasi-totalité des réacteurs de France
s'arrêter à peu près en même temps elle
va constituer une marche d'escalier très
importantes l'ensemble du du
réacteurs nucléaire actuels ont été
construits sur une courte période de
temps sur une quinzaine d'années et donc
si on part du principe qu'il serait
possible mais c'est une hypothèse de
poursuivre l'exploitation jusqu'à 60 ans
ou un peu plus des réacteurs à un moment
donné je ne sais pas quand mais après
2050 il va y avoir
un vrai sujet qui sera celui de la mise
à l'arrêt de 63
gigawatt de puissance ça va être étalé
sur une courte période de temps donc il
faut aussi anticiper ce sujet non
seulement il faut se poser la question
de l'étalement et des capacités qui
permettront de faire le relais alors je
n'ai pas moi de responsabilité en termes
de politique énergétique donc je
n'évoquerai pas tel ou tel scénario mais
je dis que c'est un sujet qui dont il
faut avoir conscience aujourd'hui le
débat ça ne doit pas être uniquement de
définir une perspective énergétique à
l'horizon 2050 dans le domaine nucléaire
il faut aussi s'interroger peut-être pas
tout de suite mais dans quelques temps
sur l'horizon d'après parce que
l'horizon d'après c'est une sacrée
marche et c'est c'est pas six ou 14
pairs c'est une sacrée marche voilà donc
un il faut bien évidemment avoir des
marges et deux il faut anticiper je
reviens sur ce que je disais dans mon
introduction
merci beaucoup alors sur six géo sur la
question oui des déchets radioactifs il
y a différentes sortes de déchets
radioactifs et il y a un instrument pour
programmer la gestion c'est le plan
national de gestion des matières et des
chaînes radioactifs ils sont de
différents types c'est déchets et
notamment ils n'ont pas tous la même
durée de vie comme on dit et donc ils ne
vont pas être tous être géré de la même
manière les les déchets très faiblement
actifs vont être gérés en surface dans
des centres de stockage de surface ce
dont on parle par rapport à six géo ce
sont les déchets qui ont la durée de vie
la plus longue et c'est une durée de vie
qui est tellement longue que finalement
le seul la seule constante de temps
qui est qui est du même ordre de
grandeur que la durée de vie de ces
déchets c'est l'échelle des temps
géologiques d'où l'idée effectivement de
de finalement quelque part de confier
ces déchets pour les gérer à la géologie
et si j'ai aussi finalement le blocage
de ces déchets à Vitré longue dans une
couche d'argile qui est à 500 mètres de
profondeur et et qui évolue finalement
au même type d'échelle de temps que les
déchets eux-mêmes alors après il y a pas
de il y a pas de négociation sur ce
sujet c'est à dire que il y a un dossier
extrêmement fouillé extrêmement
approfondi qui a été préparé par
l'Agence nationale pour la gestion des
déchets radioactifs dont c'est la
mission
et qui vient d'être déposé il y a
quelques jours seulement
pour instruction et ce dossier doit
démontrer en quoi un déchet radioactif
stocké à 500 mètres sous terre dans
cette couche d'argile avec les
caractéristiques qu'elle l'a finalement
telle qu'elle est finalement va pouvoir
être suffisamment isolé par rapport aux
personnes et à l'environnement pour
justement qu'il soit protégés de ces
déchets radioactifs et en particulier
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est étudié
de façon extrêmement précise c'est
les vitesses alors de dégradation des
ouvrages dans lesquels ces déchets
radioactifs sont stockés les vitesses le
cas échéant de migration des
radioséléments dans la couche d'argile
et justement l'un des intérêts de
l'argile c'est que les vitesses de
transport des particules en fait à
l'intérieur et de l'eau en particulier à
travers cette couche sont extrêmement
faibles extrêmement faibles ce qui fait
que il y a pas de mise en contact en
fait
où en fait seulement très
très retardé avec l'environnement et et
c'est précisément ces questions là que
nous allons maintenant instruire dans le
cadre de l'examen de cette demande
d'autorisation de création alors sachant
que un certain nombre de sujets ont déjà
été
examinés pas avec tout le niveau de
détail qui est présent dans ce dossier
c'est pour ça qu'il faut encore qu'on
l'instruise mais déjà examiner notamment
à un stade précédent qui s'appelait le
des options de sûreté et sur lequel on
s'est prononcé avec un avis
au plan général favorable par rapport
aux propositions faites par landra voilà
ce que je peux dire sur si
merci beaucoup et je passe la parole à
Madame lernos donc je profite d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui pour souligner la suite
à nos réunions je ne sais pas combien
d'heures j'ai fait mais j'en ai fait un
certain nombre également je voulais vous
remercier en tout cas pour vos propos et
puis pour le soulignage un certain
aspects qui n'avaient pas forcément été
soulignés par les industriels ou les
autres personnes que nous avons
auditionné qui n'ont pas fait que des
louanges sur les normes de sécurité mais
vous y avez répondu suite aux questions
qui ont été émises par le rapporteur il
me semble vous avez très clairement dit
que ce n'était pas les normes
réglementaires qui étaient à l'origine
des défaillances et donc non des retards
non plus notamment sur le projet de
Flamanville et je pense que votre
analyse est assez juste pour dire que la
SN a un rôle absolument majeur aussi en
termes d'acceptabilité non seulement du
prolongement des centrales mais
également sur la mise en route
éventuelle de nouveaux réacteurs dans la
mesure où le nucléaire est une matière
dangereuse par essence et donc sans
puisque radioactive et donc à des un
effet assez dévastateur on a pu en voir
un certain nombre de phénomènes sur des
accidents sur des centrales mais aussi
quand c'était en matière non utilisée
non de matière non de manière non civile
et donc de fait votre responsabilité ou
en tout cas une norme de sécurité sont
assez sont absolument indispensables
j'en venais à une question que Madame
Lepage que nous avons auditionné nous a
indiqué pour voir si c'était la réalité
madame Lepage nous disait lors de son
audition devant cette commission
d'enquête qu'en cas d'un accident
nucléaire en France c'était la
responsabilité du président de l'ASN en
tant que personne physique qui était
engagée c'était un élément que je
voulais vérifier avec vous avant de vous
poser question plus sur les autres
aspects
je ne pense pas que ça soit exact mais
non
je crois que quand on est président la
scène on doit dormir parce que quand il
le faut bien sûr parce que si on n'est
pas serein je pense qu'on aurait
certainement du mal à faire face à des
situations qui peuvent être dramatiques
non en fait si vous voulez il y a je
crois que ça dépend du régime
d'associations de d'associations
d'autorité indépendante nous sommes une
autorité administrative indépendante
nous faisons partie de l'état la
responsabilité en matière de sûreté est
assurée par l'État et ce n'est pas le
cas en revanche il pourrait y avoir
d'autres formes où il y aurait des
responsabilités notamment dans les
décisions en prises du collège mais ce
sont des autres formes d'autorité
indépendante
mais c'est pas le cas de la SN donc
voilà je mais je vais vérifier
c'est des propos qui est comme
d'audition en audition on en apprend je
voulais je le souhaitais vérifier ça
avec vous je voulais vous interroger sur
les risques vous avez parlé des risques
liés au changement climatique qui se
trouve que au Sénat lors de la
discussion et du vote de la loi
sur le nucléaire la ministre la
transition énergétique a également
confirmé qu'il y aurait là où on prévoit
éventuellement des nouveaux paires de
réacteurs vous avez parlé du manque
d'eau à juste titre du réchauffement
climatique du problème de dilution des
tensions aussi sur les ressources sur
des conflits d'usage ce qui est le cas
effectivement notamment sur les
centrales installées sur le Rhône mais
il y a aussi celles qui sont fragiles
face ou réchauffement climatique et qui
se trouve en zone inondable on peut
penser notamment à Gravelines et à Penly
donc comment cela a et anticiper pour
les anciennes ou la prolongation et y
compris pour d'éventuelles nouveaux
réacteurs un autre risque plutôt
peut-être monsieur gusta puisque vous
avez parlé brièvement responsabilité au
sein de la wienera sur les risques
notamment liés à la centrale de
zapporigia et donc les risques liés à la
guerre puisqu'on voit bien et ça a été
répété par un certain nombre
d'auditionnés qu'il fallait un climat
stable et de paix ils viennent non
seulement les investissements sur la
durée mais on voit aujourd'hui avec la
tension sur les ressources qui
s'accélèrent comment l'Autorité de
sûreté du nucléaire travaille aussi sur
les risques liés à des conflits armés et
la résistance de nos centrales ou de nos
installations par rapport à cela
j'ai d'autres questions mais qui sont du
coup plus sur ces risques là mais sur la
prolongation des centrales on l'a évoqué
vous l'avez évoqué déjà dans vos propos
mais dans le rapport de 2021 l'ASN vous
aviez indiqué que il n'y avait pas vous
n'aviez pas de quoi conclure que la
poursuite du fonctionnement de tous ces
réacteurs pouvaient aller au-delà de 50
ans ou en tout cas qu'elle n'était pas
acquise est-ce que vous avez déjà
identifié des problématiques ou des
choses qui vous permettent de dire ça
est-ce qu'il y a plus de risques de
sûreté au-delà de la prolongation de 50
ans et concernant les scénarios les plus
nucléarisés de RTE qui s'appuient
notamment sur la prolongation du parc
existant au-delà des 60 ans est-ce que
cela vous semble crédible est-ce que ils
prennent suffisamment en compte toutes
les considérations en termes de sécurité
ou est-ce que c'est encore prématuré à
votre sens
j'avais aussi une question dans l'édito
que vous avez fait en 2021 de ce même
rapport vous indiquez que la qualité la
rigueur de la conception de la
fabrication et du contrôle des
installations nucléaires n'étaient pas
au niveau attendu dans les derniers
grands projets nucléaires en France je
crois que vous l'avez répété également
dans vos vœux hier
pour vous c'est quoi les raisons de ce
manque de rigueur parce que c'est les
exigences de rentabilité d'EDF ou la
question de la sous-traitance a été
évoquée rapidement ça fait aussi partie
des questions sur votre rapport
d'inspection notamment sur l'usine de
sous-traitance en Italie je reviendrai
pas dessus puisque vous connaissez très
bien les choses mais peut-être que vous
avez des précisions sur les conditions
qui règnent dans cette usine et pourquoi
vous avez dû contrôler à nouveau pour
voir que les pièces qui étaient
remplacées avec les mêmes problématiques
que celle qui qu'elle visait à remplacé
je trouve de ce point de vue là le fait
que dans les principes que vous avez
édité la que vous n'êtes pas là pour des
responsabiliser l'industrie elle qui est
en charge est important parce qu'on a
l'impression parfois que EDF ne
n'indique pas des défaillances
d'eux-mêmes et que vous avez un rôle
assez fondamental de pouvoir les
repenter sur un certain nombre de
contrôles une question on a interrogé
plusieurs de vos prédécesseurs ou
prédécesseuses sur les piscines vous y
avez répondu notamment à lag pour la
première fois on a une forme de réponse
avec les trois parades que vous nous
avez exposé
pour autant on a l'impression qui a un
format d'anticipation sur la saturation
et que il faut avoir recours à des
parades quand il s'agit de déchets
nucléaires est-ce très sérieux c'est une
question la poursuite du retraitement du
combustible
usé là aussi vous écrivez dans votre
rapport de 2021 que d'ici la fin de la
décennie au plus tard le gouvernement
devrait se prononcer sur la poursuite ou
non du retrait de banc des combustible
usés à l'horizon 2040 pour en anticiper
les conséquences et les investissements
pensez-vous enfin quel est votre
position sur le sujet si vous en avez
une si vous êtes autorisé à en avoir une
en termes de sûreté bien sûr et
pensez-vous qu'il soit judicieux de
continuer à poursuivre cette activité au
regard de la situation de la saturation
donc toujours en termes de sûreté
dernière question c'est sur le design de
l'EPR 2 dans le rapport
travaux relatifs aux nouveaux nucléaire
une des évolutions conceptuelles qui est
mise en avant pour le PR2 et la
conception par EDF d'une simple enceinte
remplaçant la double enceinte de
confinement de l'EPR certes cette
enceinte simple est censée comporter un
revêtement métallique interne cependant
quelle est la vie de l'ASN puisque ça
paraît contre-intuitif en terme de norme
de sécurité et sûreté est-ce que vous
êtes en capacité d'affirmer que cette
deuxième enceinte de confinement n'est
pas nécessaire et est-ce que vous avez
validé d'ores et déjà ce design je suis
désolé ça fait beaucoup de questions
mais voilà je profite de l'occasion de
vous avoir et d'avoir une réponse à un
certain nombre d'éléments
non ça simplement comme nous sommes deux
la question c'est de savoir que qui va
répondre à quoi c'est tout alors ça
pourrait tu vois bien évidemment ce sera
Olivier puis ensuite on va répartir
alors sur la première question je crois
qui concernait la question des zones
inondables alors vous avez tout à fait
raison il y a c'est un sujet qui doit
être pris en compte dans le cas des
effets un réchauffement climatique il y
a finalement deux phénomènes qui peuvent
être pris en compte il y a d'abord
l'élévation du montée des eaux de la
montée des eaux il y a plusieurs
scénarios
pessimistes sur ce qui va se passer à
l'avenir et puis il y a les événements
climatiques eux-mêmes qui peuvent
conduire à des vagues de submersion
marines avec des effets comme d'ailleurs
on a connu à sur la centrale du Blayais
donc par rapport à ces deux ces deux
risques d'aléables évidemment ce sont
des risques qui sont qui sont évalués au
regard des prévisions de l'élévation du
niveau de l'eau ou de l'intensification
des des risques de submers sous-marine
pour que les centrales claires se
protègent et elles se protège ça a été
le cas au blayer c'est le cas aussi à
gravier par la mise en place de digues
racines dans le cadre de la quatrième
visite décennale a été décidée de mettre
la totalité de renforcer la totalité du
site sur la totalité ça circonférence
son périmètre par des des moyens de
protection pour en cas de submersion
marine et venant des zones périphériques
c'est pas uniquement la façade de la
centrale face à la mer mais c'est le
fait que l'eau peut s'infiltrer à côté
une partie de droite et ensuite revenir
par l'entrée du site d'une certaine
totalité du site qui a été qui a été
protégé bon donc c'est un sujet qui est
qui est bien je crois identifié qui fait
l'objet de manière régulière de
d'amélioration en matière de protection
et pour les nouvelles installations
nucléaires en bord de mer et ben il
faudra en tenir compte notamment en ce
qui concerne le niveau de de la
plateforme sur laquelle va être mise en
place la centrale nucléaire pour que
elle puisse être un niveau de protection
suffisant par rapport au risque
d'élévation de du niveau de la mer alors
c'est un sujet qui
pour nous doit faire l'objet d'une
réflexion plus large parce que on peut
toujours se protéger en mettant des
digues de plus en plus haute moi je suis
allé au Japon j'ai vu que on mettait des
digues de plus en plus c'est possible
mais à un moment donné il faut aussi
s'interroger sur l'environnement dans
lequel on se trouve s'il y a
effectivement une montée des eaux qui
conduit par exemple dans la zone de
Gravelines à avoir la totalité du
Dunkerquois qui soit sous l'eau bon on
peut toujours imaginer une centrale sur
une île mais il y a quand même un
problème tout autour et donc c'est
exactement la question que nous posons
en disant il faut pas seulement je citer
beaucoup d'exemples sur les centrales
nucléaires anciennes et nouvelles sur
les bords des fleuves mais aussi sur les
les centrales nucléaires en façade avoir
une vision long terme des risques et se
poser la question de l'homme moyen de se
protéger mais de le faire de manière
territorialisée il faut regarder le
territoire qui est autour de la centrale
pas résonner purement EDF regardez sur
le territoire il y a plein de
conséquences que ça peut avoir si le
niveau des oeuvres est élevé voilà donc
voilà je pense qu'il faut il faut
vraiment travailler sur sur ce sujet là
de façon générale sur les la résistance
des installations nucléaires à ce type
de situation
ce qu'il faut voir c'est que ça reste
quand même parmi les installations qui
qui résistent le mieux à ce type de
situation pourquoi parce que les
bâtiments des installations nucléaires
sont constituées de de bâtiments enfin
de parois en béton en général
extrêmement épais pour d'autres raisons
pour la tenue au cialisme pour la tenue
y compris par rapport à des phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes mais de fait ça
offre aussi on évoquait tout à l'heure
la chute d'avion mais ça offre aussi de
fait un niveau un certain niveau de
protection face à des armes y compris
des armes de guerre il y a la redondance
aussi des systèmes de sûreté qui est qui
est un élément favorable enfin voilà il
y a tout un tas d'éléments qui sont qui
sont qui vont dans le bon sens pour
autant
aucune installation
populaire et conçu pour résister
absolument à tous les moyens de
destruction qui existent et qui sont à
disposition de tel ou telle armée donc
voilà ça c'est ça c'est évident
le point sur lequel on insiste en
particulier dans le cas de la centrale
de zapporo Dias et finalement outre ces
questions de de risques de tir ou
d'endommagement de matériel il y en a eu
des endommagements de matériel mais
finalement ils sont restés relativement
limités notre sujet de préoccupation
aujourd'hui c'est plus un sujet d'ordre
organisationnel et humain c'est à dire
le fait que notamment ces dernières
semaines et ces derniers mois avec la
prise de contrôle par les Russes de la
centrale un risque que alors c'était
déjà le cas avec la des des claques à
démarrer mais encore plus maintenant le
risque que les équipes en fait elles
soient pas dans les conditions de
sérénité
[Musique]
propice finalement à l'exécution des
bons gestes que ce soit en
fonctionnement normal ou qui plus est en
situation
d'incident ou s'il fallait gérer un
accident est-ce que les les informations
vont remonter entre les équipes de
terrain et la direction de la centrale
sachant que la direction elle a été
remplacée par les Russes par des
personnels qu'ils ont eux-mêmes nommé
comment se connectent-ils ces personnels
ou aux Ukrainiens qui sont restés en
poste au niveau du terrain voilà c'est
le type de question aujourd'hui qui nous
préoccupe
en particulier donc sur la centrale de
Gien
alors je vais reprendre sur suite au
delà de 50 ans et puis scénario RTE
au-delà de 60 ans donc je vais indiquer
tout à l'heure en fait les éléments qui
nous ont été fournis par EDF à ce stade
ne justifiait la poursuite
d'exploitation des réacteurs les plus
anciens 900 MW notamment pour la cuve
que jusqu'à 50 ans donc EDF c'est Calais
par rapport au pas des Sénats ce qui
nous a pas permis d'engager une
discussion pour au-delà c'était pas
anormal puisque l'objectif est de rendre
décision sur les 10 ans qui suivaient
donc aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
visibilité au-delà de 50 ans première
chose c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour
laquelle maintenant on souhaite en avoir
et en se disant il s'agit pas de passer
de 50 à 60 il s'agit d'aller plus loin
sur les quelques points sensibles c'est
ce que je disais je ne reviens pas
là-dessus alors les scénarios de RTE là
c'est aussi un élément tout à fait
importante dans notre réflexion dans
notre prise de parole c'est que le
scénario le plus nucléarisé comme vous
avez est un scénario dans lequel RT
postule une durée d'exploitation d'un
certain nombre de réacteurs au-delà de
60 ans et puis une grande partie du
reste au moins jusqu'à 60 ans j'ai
compris récemment qu'ils dans leur
scénario il y avait aussi quelques
réacteurs qui s'arrêtaient à 50 mais peu
importe enfin la grosse majorité c'est
au moins 60 et c'est voir beaucoup plus
donc nous ce que nous disons c'est que
tout ça n'est pas justifié aujourd'hui
il y a rien puisque les justifications
qui nous ont été données c'est jusqu'à
50 ans et le point d'alerte principal
c'est que nous nous voulons pas que la
politique énergétique soit basée sur des
hypothèses structurantes qui ne sont pas
étayées ou vérifier c'est pour ça que
nous disons il faut il faut dès à
présent se préoccuper de ce sujet avec
une perspective suivie par lointaine
parce qu'il ne faudrait pas je vais
reprendre une expression je mets
Autocité mais vous la connaissez
certainement il ne faudrait pas que la
poursuite d'exploitation des réacteurs
nucléaires soit la véritable
d'ajustement d'une politique énergétique
qui aurait été mal calibrée parce qu'on
peut toujours
afficher et on peut le croire qu'on va
réussir à faire telle chose en termes de
développement des EnR qu'on va réussir à
faire telle chose en matière
d'efficacité énergétique en matière de
sobriété on peut afficher plein plein de
choses mais c'est finalement ça ne se
produit pas et qu'on n'a pas de marge
dans ce que l'on a déterminé le risque
tout à l'heure on parlait de risque de
mise en tension de la sûreté par rapport
à d'autres ça serait peut-être de dire
mais pourquoi donc ne pas poursuivre
l'exploitation encore un peu plus des
réacteurs nucléaires regardez ce qui
s'est passé en Belgique regardez ce qui
s'est passé en Allemagne en Belgique et
en Allemagne on a quand même été dans
une situation un peu maintenant les
choses ont un peu évolué mais au
démarrage un peu paradoxal il y avait
quelques années quelques années
auparavant les exploitants disaient à
leur gouvernement qui voulaient arrêter
les centrales on ne comprend pas
pourquoi vous les voulez les arrêter
parce qu'elles fonctionnent en toute
sûreté des exploitants ne comprenaient
pas pourquoi il fallait les arrêter et
puis donc et ensuite ça s'est retourné
les gouvernements ont dit maintenant il
faudrait poursuivre l'exploitation parce
qu'on en a besoin et les exploitants ont
dit bah oui m'attendez on n'est pas prêt
il y a des risques pour la sûreté donc
voilà évitons ce genre de situation ou
finalement par des à-coups de politique
énergétique ou des sous-dimensionnement
on se retrouverait devant une question
c'est mais pourquoi pas encore augmenter
la durée d'exploitation donc il faut
anticiper et il faut le faire sur la
base de justification solide argumentée
que nous pouvons instruire c'est ce que
nous demandons c'est ce que j'ai
expliqué ici est-ce que j'ai expliqué
hier voilà c'est ça que nous souhaitons
et nous souhaitons que ça soit inscrire
en dur dans les obligations de de
l'exploitant dans le cas de la prochaine
PPE ça permet de couvrir je crois les
deux sujets sur les 50 ans et les 60 ans
la rigueur de conception de fabrication
et de contrôle c'est vrai que dans notre
rapport on a pointé du doigt ce sujet et
c'est particulièrement vrai pour les
nouveaux projets ça a été le cas sur sur
le Pr et là encore je vais me référer au
rapport de Jean-Martin folles
l'explication est extrêmement
clair et le lancement du projet père de
Flamanville a été fait alors que les
études de conception détaillaient
n'étaient pas achevées
certaines demandes ont été faites
comment ont été faites auprès de
prestataires puis ensuite les plans ont
changé ce qu'il fallait faire a été
modifié il y a eu donc toute une série
de d'études préalables indispensables au
lancement du projet qui n'était pas
présente ensuite il y a eu toute une
série de pertes de compétences et
d'expérience qui ont conduit et de perte
de rigueur qui ont conduit à des je
reviens pas non plus là aussi sur ce que
j'ai dit à des procédés industriels mis
en oeuvre sem préalable et sans métier
et ça n'avait rien à voir avec la
réglementation donc on voit bien qu'il y
a eu et puis tout ça n'a pas été détecté
comme il fallait moi je me souviens très
bien d'une audition parlementaire à
l'OPEX sur le cas de la traversée
enceinte suite à notre décision de 2019
au printemps 2019 il y a on a été une
audition sur ce sujet et j'ai rappelé
j'ai expliqué ce qui s'était passé en
fait le défaut sur les traversées
enceintes avaient été découvert par
l'exploitant en 2015
nous en arriverons étaient informés en
2017 il y a une défaillance dans le
contrôle et dans l'information
voilà ensuite il y a eu une logique qui
s'est installée de la part de framatum
et d'EDF qui est de dire bon on va
justifier on va justifier que cet
acceptable en état il n'y a pas eu de
décision de réparation le contrôle n'a
pas conduit et la surveillance n'a pas
conduit à une décision de correction ce
qui est d'ailleurs une attitude très
différente maintenant
clairement que quand on trouve un écart
on le répare à l'époque trouver un écart
on met deux ans elle vendent le déclarer
et puis on parie sur le fait qu'on va
pouvoir le justifier parfois on gagne
parfois on gagne pas c'est ce qui s'est
passé et tout ça ensuite c'est enchaîné
et à conduit à une décision extrêmement
pénalisante en ce qui concerne la
conduite du chantier je voulais avoir
dit au cours de cette commission que les
Finlandais ont aussi découvert un
problème sur les soudures de traverser
enceinte
c'était un problème différent c'était
pas la qualité du soudage mais c'était
la qualité du matériau
ont découvert à peu près au même stade
où se trouvaient le réacteur la
construction du réacteur de Flamanville
quand le problème a été découvert
c'était pareil la même situation c'est à
dire que les le reste des circuits
n'avaient pas été installés et
connectées il y avait que la traversée
enceinte ils ont pris la décision de la
remplacer tout de suite ça a duré 9 mois
en 9 mois ils ont géré le problème
regardez le temps qu'il a fallu qu'il
faut qu'il fallait compte tenu du de
l'installation totale pour EDF pour
réparer traverser ensemble donc il y a
vraiment eu des défaillances en termes
de conduite de projet en termes de
qualité de fabrication de rigueur de
fabrication de contrôle et de décision
la justification le pari de la
justification a posteriorer est un pari
hasardeux ça peut marcher ça peut ne pas
marcher ce n'est pas un pari à faire
quand on construit du nucléaire donc
voilà c'est un et les choses ont été me
semble-t-il on verra bien mais les
retours expérience a été tirée pour voir
les choses de manière très différente on
le voit bien dans la des études de
conception détaillées de l'oppr2 les
choses sont beaucoup plus avancées donc
la conduite de projet sera différente ça
a été tirée mais bon ça a été très très
difficile
voilà peut-être sur les autres sujets
ici sur la piscine entre vos âges du
combustible naturellement il aurait été
préférable qu'elle soit prête à temps et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que il y a déjà
plusieurs années ce fameux PNG mdr
appelé à la construction d'une telle
capacité d'entreposage après les
périodes les parades oui elles sont
sérieuses en termes de sûreté ça ils
vont être les dossiers seront déposés
certains l'ont déjà été et naturellement
on va l'examiner avec la rigueur qui est
la nôtre et voilà pour pour s'assurer
que il n'y a pas de de régression en
matière de sûreté
sur les le retraitement des combustibles
usés je le redis c'est réellement une
décision et un choix de politique
énergétique
nous notre notre rôle ça sera de
vérifier que ce choix finalement il est
cohérent dans son ensemble c'est à dire
que il y a pas de zone d'ombre il n'y a
pas d'impasse
dans laquelle nous il nous mènerait qui
qui ferait prendre des risques en termes
toujours pareil de protection des
personnes et de l'environnement et
ensuite naturellement dossier après
dossier on examinera la sûreté des
installations constituant ce cycle quel
que soit ceci que ce soit un cycle de
mono recyclage que ce soit du multiro
cyclage en réacteur à neutron thermique
ou un cycle incluant un parc de réacteur
à neutrons rapides ou bien pas de cycle
du tout c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle le
cycle ouvert que que font un certain
nombre ça c'est réellement un choix de
politique énergétique et enfin sur le
design de le PR2
la SN avait pris position sur les
options de sûreté de le PR2 avec un
sujet mis en réserve mais qui a été levé
depuis qui est le sujet de l'exclusion
de rupture et au total aujourd'hui notre
position est qu'il y a pas de il y a pas
d'objection au design tel qu'il est
envisagé en tout cas pour pour ce qui
relève de la partie instruite par par la
SN
peut-être juste un complément je reviens
sur la sur la poursuite du retraitement
donc c'est un sujet que nous avons mis
en avant là encore toujours avec l'idée
d'anticiper dans la PPA actuelle
l'installation de retraitement de lag et
prévu jusqu'en 2040 donc ce que nous
savons c'est pour aller au-delà de toute
façon il faudra vraisemblablement si une
décision politique sur laquelle la SN
n'a pas à prendre position c'est une
décision politique de poursuite du
retraitement et été prise il faudrait
vraisemblablement procéder à minima un
grand carénage de l'installation de lag
comme EDF le fait sur les installations
ses réacteurs et peut-être même prévoir
une rénovation d'une partie des
installations voir une nouvelle
installation
et la question d'ailleurs de la des
piscines actuelles se posera parce que
là on pourrait très bien imaginer dans
une rénovation des piscines qui soient
mieux protégées que celle d'aujourd'hui
donc il faudra se poser la question et
ça ça prend beaucoup de temps parce que
avant de de concevoir et de réaliser une
installation qui prendra le relais de
l'installation de lac ou un grand
carénage sur l'installation de la Hague
et ben il faut du temps tout à l'heure
je vais donner les causes des temps pour
la quatrième visite des Sénat donc c'est
c'est dans les quelques années qui
viennent les trois ans qui viennent
qu'il faut se positionner est-ce qu'on
poursuit ou pas et si on décidait
politiquement de dire on arrête le
retraitement et bien il faut là aussi 10
ans pour pouvoir trouver la solution
alternative l'entreposage à sec avant
d'envisager bien sûr les conséquences
sur la gestion à long terme des stockage
des déchets donc il faut il faut du
temps donc là aussi il faut il faut
anticiper c'est pour ça que nous disons
et nous avons dit hier que en fait la
réflexion d'anticipation elle doit
porter sur toutes les composantes du
système nucléaire il faut pas uniquement
réfléchir l'anticipation de la poursuite
d'exploitation des réacteurs il faut
réfléchir à la situation pour les les
installations du cycle du combustible et
puis il faut étudier la conséquence de
tout ça sur les installations de de
stockage des déchets c'est le cycle tout
est lié on est dans une approche
systémique en fait et c'est tout ça
qu'il faut regarder dans les quelques
années qui viennent
merci vous avez ouvert tout à l'heure
une porte dans votre réponse sur le
retour d'expérience dont on pourrait
profiter du d'un certain nombre de
partis pris et d'expérience américaine
vous avez évoqué un peu le sujet sur la
question de du dialogue entre études
probabiliste et déterministe est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres points qui pour vous
semblent intéressant dans dans ce
dialogue international notamment avec
les États-Unis
il y a déjà à la base tout le retour
d'expérience de du fonctionnement des
installations c'est à dire tous les
incidents qui se produisent ici et là
sur les différents réacteurs dans tel ou
tel pays et qui sont source dans
saignement le cas échéant
il y a des discussions sur les méthodes
de contrôle
typiquement enfin juste pour prendre cet
exemple là alors c'est un exemple qui
commence à dater mais la SN fait ce
qu'on appelle les inspections de revues
c'est à dire
c'est l'idée de passer une semaine sur
une installation avec une équipe d'une
vingtaine d'inspecteurs qui finalement
passe l'installation peigne fin
l'ensemble des des sujets sont regardés
beaucoup plus que dans une inspection
courante qui ne dure qu'une journée avec
deux inspecteurs typiquement et ben
cette formule des inspections de revues
elle est directement inspirée du
dialogue avec avec nos homologues qu'il
a pratiqué et finalement on a importé
cette façon de faire chez nous voilà
ça arrive aussi dans l'autre sens et et
outre là tous les tous les cercles
internationaux qu'on a évoqué il y a
énormément de relations bilatérales
Bernard de Rosu qui était encore une
semaine ou deux semaines justement aux
États-Unis pour pour des discussions
enfin voilà chacun d'entre vous on a des
discussions avec nos homologues pour en
convaincre que ce soit sur les
installations elles-mêmes ou sur les
méthodes de contrôle
c'est intéressant parce que c'est dans
les deux sens en fait on n'est pas
uniquement en situation d'écoute de ce
qui est fait à l'étranger et je prends
l'exemple
qu'on a évoqué à plusieurs reprises
celui de la poursuite d'exploitation
donc on a dit à nos homologues
américains finalement vous avez 10-15
ans d'avance par rapport à nous et c'est
logique puisque votre parc a 10-15 ans
d'avance donc ils se sont posés les
questions que nous nous posons il y a
10-15 ans donc quand on regarde la
situation nous disons pas oui on n'est
pas en retard on se pose les questions
au même moment que les Américains sauf
qu'on a des disques un an trop tard
enfin de regarde de décalage pardon sur
sur la vie du parc et on leur a dit bah
nous on a on a regardé on a commencé à
regarder un certain nombre de sujets et
là on a pensé alors sur un cas très
particulier ce sont des coudes qui sont
des coups de Moulet qui sont fixés à la
cuve du réacteur nous on estime qu'il y
a un sujet un vrai sujet c'est très
difficile à imaginer de remplacer ses
coudes parce que ça serait proche du
réacteur donc il y aurait un effet
dosant très fort il faudrait faire
certainement avec des robots enfin c'est
très compliqué et on l'a dit à nous on a
regardé en regardant la manière dont
c'est fabriqué la manière dont on peut
inspecter voir la taille des défauts on
estime que là il y a un composant
fragile qui est peut-être parfois sur
certains facteurs plus fragiles que la
cuve elle-même c'est peut-être le coup
de moulin qui qui déterminerait la durée
de vie on a dit mais est-ce que vous
avez regardé vous et aujourd'hui bah non
nous venons on n'a pas regardé et donc
on voit bien que
on leur a aussi
mis en avant un sujet que nous nous
avions identifié que eux n'avait pas
regardé et finalement ils vont regarder
donc on peut là encore dans un échange
de cette nature dans les deux sens
bénéficier de l'expérience des des uns
et des autres
alors justement sur ce genre de sujet
pour une fois je parle de Fessenheim
actuellement il y a une opération de
décontamination du circuit primaire qui
est en qui est en cours enfin qui est
achevé sur le premier directeur et qui
va débuter dans quelques jours sur le
second est-ce que c'est quelque chose
que vous regardez dans la perspective
justement de la réduction de la
contamination et donc du caractère
d'Osan du circuit primaire en cas
d'intervention dessus dans l'éventuelle
perspective d'opérations de maintien de
carénage ou de prolongation du parc
oui alors là on est effectivement sur
les réacteurs de Fessenheim on est dans
une phase de près démantèlement qui
consiste à préparer les opérations plus
lourdes qui arriveront par la suite et
parmi ces opérations de près des
mentalement il y a celles qui consiste à
éliminer au maximum
la matière radioactive qui est fixée au
circuit primaire principal donc c'est
une opération
un peu de décapage assez robuste qui
permet de d'enlever une bonne partie de
la radioactivité qui a été fixée par le
métal lui-même donc le ça conduit
nécessairement à aussi il faut le dire à
une diminution de l'épaisseur du méthane
donc c'est important toutes ces cette
approche là est une approche qui est
basée sur un retour d'expérience de
démantèlement de réacteurs à eau sous
pression c'est la différence entre le
démantèlement d'un réacteur comme
Fessenheim par rapport aux installations
atypiques ou spécifiques qu'on peut
avoir par ailleurs pour il y a pas de
retour d'expérience là il y en a donc
c'est une opération qui a été faite
ailleurs à l'étranger sur lesquels on
prend le retour d'expérience et on sait
qu'elle est favorable à la gestion
ensuite du chantier en termes
d'exposition des travailleurs
exposition rayonnement ionisante donc
c'est une opération qui a été faite sur
la réacteur 1 qui va être faite sur le
réacteur 2 et l'opération est prévue
dans ce planning et ça se passe ça se
passe très bien il y a le centre
Fessenheim m'a vraiment à coeur on le
sent et ça n'a rien à voir bien sûr avec
la décision mais de réaliser une
opération de tête de série exemplaire en
matière de de démantèlement qui puisse
servir pour le parc nucléaire dans le
futur
c'était pas vraiment la question
je crois que vous avez bien compris que
c'était pas la question non mais moi
la possibilité du de mobiliser cette
technique l'expérience acquise de cette
technique pour
réduire la dose dans le sur le circuit
primaire et peut-être faciliter des
interventions de maintenance ou de
grands carénage ou qui seront
nécessaires en cas de prolongations
agressive c'est pour ça que je dis
attention on perd de l'épaisseur donc
faire cela pour sur un réacteur en
service je suis passé il faut avoir sur
votre capable de justifier dans la
démonstration de sûreté le fait qu'on
réduit l'épaisseur du circuit freezer
principal donc ça peut se concevoir dans
une étape préalable à un des mentalement
c'est totalement exclu de le faire dans
un dispositif dans une installation en
fonctionnement
dernière question pour moi
au cours de l'audition de d'EDF d'un des
démembrements d'EDF qu'on a pu faire
il nous a été indiqué que une attention
a été portée par l'entreprise
à un certain nombre de composants
qui étaient jusque là hors SCOP un petit
peu c'est pas décomposant qui était
habituellement remplacés donc pas des
pièces d'usure pas non plus des
composants à enjeu majeurs dans le cadre
d'un grand carénage mais un peu
la pièce qui est qui est là qui dérange
pas qui bouge pas trop que qui pose pas
de problème jusque là et qui semble pas
poser de difficultés particulières mais
qui pourrait un jour imposer s'il
fallait la remplacer est-ce que c'est
quelque chose sur quoi vous vous
travaillez aussi finalement
identifier ces éléments qu'ils étaient
jusque là hors
et enfin
c'est juste pour bien comprendre ce que
ce que chacun met derrière certains mots
dans la façon d'aborder
l'âge à venir du parc donc les étapes
successives de visite décennale dans son
discours
généraliste sur la stratégie énergétique
il y a quelques semaines Elisabeth borne
a indiqué réfléchir en lien avec EDF et
la SN à
identifier les réacteurs qui ne
dépasseront pas les 50 ans
c'est une formulation qui a un peu à
rebours des démonstrations que vous avez
faites vous avez plutôt
démontré que vous réfléchissez à quels
sont les jets à longs comment on fait
pour passer
les 50 ans et permettre les choix donc
est-ce qu'il y a un bien dans la
présentation et est-ce que c'est moi qui
ai mal compris ce qu'a dit Elisabeth
borne ou
non je crois que il y a à la fois la
démarche générale que j'ai présenté et
puis il y a la nécessité de s'interroger
sur des éventuelles cas particuliers
la démarche c'est bien celle qui
consiste tout en maintenant les réamens
des scénos donc on va ouvrir le l'examen
décennale des réacteurs de 1300 MW la
quatrième visite décennale et d'ici
quelques années pas beaucoup on va
commencer à prévoir leur cinquième
examen des réacteurs de 900 m pour aller
de 50 à 60 pour l'instant les réacteurs
sont autorisés pour aller jusqu'à 50
donc on va ça c'est la démarche générale
et puis il peut y avoir un certain
nombre de cas particulier sur le parc
nucléaire pour lequel indépendamment de
la démarche générale il y a des cas
spécifiques à étudier je vais prendre
deux exemples sans pour autant et je
tiens à le dire que il y ait aujourd'hui
de décision ou de particulière sur ces
sites mais le site de Bugey c'est un
site cp0 donc c'est un site qui qui a un
palier qui est différent
des autres réacteurs de 900 MW et donc
par conception il est un peu différent
du CP y la question peut se poser de
savoir si c'est ce réacteur là devrait
ces questions typiques de l'examen
devrait faire l'objet d'un traitement
particulier ou d'un examen particulier
dans le cadre de la poursuite
d'exploitation au-delà de 50 ans
je prends un deuxième exemple nous avons
connu il y a pas si longtemps que ça un
séisme au tail qui est juste proche du
site de Cruas
le sujet est encore en cours d'expertise
pour savoir finalement s'il y a une
faille ou est-ce qu'elle est si elle
pourrait être active etc en fonction des
résultats de cette expertise peut-être
il y aura-t-il une décision particulière
à prendre sur le site de Cruas
voyez-vous ce particulier donc lorsque
la première ministre dit on va regarder
au-delà de 50 ans ça peut faire partie
des sujets spécifiques qui sont regardés
au delà de 50 ans mais mais il y a en
plus c'est la démarche générale que je
présentais précédemment
merci monsieur le Président une toute
dernière question dans la continuité des
échanges qu'on avait tout à l'heure sur
l'émission de la SN et le contenu de ce
sur quoi elle se prononce avec les
principes que vous avez énoncés dont le
principe de de proportionnalité
quel serait votre avis sur la
possibilité premièrement ou bien
d'élargir les missions de de la SN à et
d'intégrer les autres enjeux au-delà de
la proportion entre
la sûreté et
l'impact des mesures que vous prenez ou
que vous recommandez de prendre pour
répondre à l'enjeu de sûreté et ou
deuxièmement à minima est-ce que vous ne
jugeriez pas utile que dans les
décisions et dans l'explication des
décisions prises par la SN ou des
recommandations prises par l'ASN soit
intégrée une partie qui ne relève pas
directement de la sûreté mais de le
désenjeux énergétiques de l'impact
correct la fermeture de telles ou tel
réacteur pour des raisons de sûreté tout
à fait justifiées ou justifier par
ailleurs mais qu'elle aurait sur un
aspect environnemental si je pousse
jusqu'à la car on parlait
d'environnement si l'arrêt d'une tranche
conduit à l'importation d'électricité
produite par du charbon on peut par
exemple dire non pas qu'il y a un
arbitrage mais en tout cas qui a une
conséquence environnementale qui mérite
d'être notée
élargir la mission de l'ASN je dirais
que à ce stade hormis le sujet que j'ai
évoqué en introduction c'est à dire la
sécurité des installations nucléaires
nous n'avons pas de de réflexion ou de
demandes ou propositions particulières à
faire dans le sens de ce que vous dites
en termes d'élargissement du du des
missions allant au-delà de la sûreté des
personnes et
l'environnement donc aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas un sujet que nous avons ouvert
et je pense que c'est un sujet sur
lequel il faut qu'on nous restions
prudents en ce qui concerne le
positionnement institutionnel de la SN
et les prises de position de l'ASM je
pense que quand on se compare aux autres
autorités mondiales importantes elles
sont toutes bien centrées sur le sujet
de la sûreté le contrôle de la sûreté de
la radioprotection et il y a d'ailleurs
dans les règles internationales
une règle générale qui est extrêmement
qui consiste à séparer les fonctions de
contrôle de la sûreté de tout autre
fonction en rapport avec la politique
énergétique ou d'autres considérations
que celles de la sûreté je pense que
cette règle générale elle est importante
elle assure aussi notre crédibilité
internationale et on voit parfois dans
certains pays qui sont j'allais dire
j'allais dire moins démocratique je
n'aurais pas utiliser ce terme enfin
pour lequel l'autorité peut avoir
certains certaines pressions des
pouvoirs publics on voit les choses qui
peuvent être dangereuses et donc je
pense qu'il faut que nous conservions
cette séparation et ce cœur de mission
qui est celui de l'autorité sûreté
nucléaire actuellement
on est sur le deuxième bout de la
question sur le pardon
sur les impacts notamment bon vous avez
évoqué le fait que s'il y avait un
arrêté voilà l'arrêt d'une d'un réacteur
ça ça conduirait éventuellement à se
fournir d'électricité
produite par des moyens plus plus
impactant en termes de réchauffement
climatique la question peut se poser
pour n'importe quel moyen pas seulement
d'ailleurs pour le nucléaire dans ce je
ce sont des sujets que nous n'abordons
pas et d'ailleurs je ne vois pas comment
c'est très difficile de notamment dans
un système électrique qui en permanence
et en continu recherche un équilibre
offre de demande avec des moyens
interconnectés on ne sait pas où d'où
viendrait exactement en substitution de
l'électricité non produite par un moyen
nucléaire quel serait nous les viendrait
sur quelle source je ne sois pas bien
commun pour évaluer mais en tout cas ça
n'est pas dans notre mission et ça ne
paraît pas être de quelque chose qu'il
faudrait que nous intégrions et je
reviens sur la première réponse il faut
conserver le cœur de notre activité sur
le contrôle de la sûr de la radio
protection
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président de
rosuk merci beaucoup Monsieur le
Directeur Général
ucta voilà trois heures d'audition qui
nous ont permis je crois de d'aller au
fond des choses merci pour votre
disponibilité je donne rendez-vous au
membre de notre commission d'enquête
demain pour la poursuite de nos travaux
et je vous souhaite une bonne soirée
merci